We, we are ready to start the meeting.
We, we are ready. We'll give a couple minutes to quiet down.
Can you hear me okay, Lacey? Uh, yes, I can hear you.
Okay, perfect. We'll go ahead and get started. Uh, before we call the
meeting to order, I've asked Brett Wright, Council Member Wright, if he'd offer a prayer.
So, uh, when it's quiet there, Brett, if you'd, uh, lead us out.
Our Heavenly Father, we're grateful this evening to be able to bow our heads in
prayer and express gratitude for the opportunity to gather as fellow,
fellow citizens. We're grateful to live
in this great city, in this great state and in the United
States of America and to be able to enjoy the freedoms and opportunity
to pursue life in the way that we choose.
We express gratitude for the many blessings that we have, for the safety that we
enjoy, for one another's camaraderie and companionship.
We pray, Father, as we're about to embark in several
hours of discussion and opportunity to listen, we pray that thou bless us with listening
ears and listening hearts. Bless us with those
of us who will speak, those of us who have come with an opportunity to
express comment and thoughts and,
and with a desire to help the city council hear the
concerns that they may want to raise. Bless those
that will speak with the ability to articulate their words,
to be able to do so in the allotted time. Bless us with civility
one to another. Bless us to be
appropriate in our actions, to maintain at all times
the decorum that is expected in this public setting.
We express gratitude for our employees, for our first responders,
for those who are serving in the military. We pray that we'll be mindful of
them and their families. Bless us to be aware of those who are
less fortunate than us, those who are in need.
Help us to continue to be the great neighbors that Eagle Mountain is known for.
And these things we humbly pray in the name of Jesus Christ, amen. Amen.
Amen. Okay,
thank you, Brett. I appreciate it. Um, it is 6:02,
and we'll officially call this meeting to order and, uh, ask that
everybody stand and join Craig, who's going to lead us in the— Councilor Whiting will
lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance. Yeah, if you could join me in the
Pledge of Allegiance.
Okay, thanks, Councilmember Whiting. Uh, just to start
off, a couple of housekeeping items. First of all, I appreciate everybody accommodating me being
remote. Uh, I can see a full house there,
and I appreciate everybody showing up. We love it when people participate and,
uh, come to the, to the meetings to help us
make these difficult decisions for our city. Uh,
I love technology and the fact that we're able to still join.
I see there's quite a few participants online as well.
Mayor, we're having a hard time hearing you. If you could speak right into the
mic, it would be greatly appreciated. Okay, is that
better? Yes,
thank you. Okay. Yes, we appreciate you guys
being there, and I'm sad that I'm not there in person due to a
previous obligation, but I appreciate the fact that we can still join remote
and have these same conversations. So,
with that, we'll start. I saw— it looked like Natalie was passing out
some packets. There are packets at the back of the room
with the following documents available, just for public knowledge.
It is the property tax impact schedule form from
Eagle Mountain City. Also, a physical copy
of the Utah County Notice of Proposed Tax Increase is
available for review. The agenda is in that packet
as well, and the Truth in Taxation overview or basics.
And also, for more information, you can visit em.gov
for— or eaglemountain.gov for additional information on
our website. I know our communications team's kept that up, and it's, uh,
it's been very good. So any other information that you're
looking for, hopefully those are the areas you can find it. And if you need
a packet, it's at the back of the room. Um,
we're going to start with the agenda item 3A, which is the public hearing
for proposed Property tax increase. Uh, there will be some rules,
just like as our, uh, other meetings, some decorum.
As was mentioned before, we expect everybody to be respectful and to
follow the rules and, uh, make sure we handle this
with respect. This public hearing is for the proposed property
tax increase. Please keep your comments related to this topic
only. The council will listen to all comments but will not engage
in a discussion until the public hearing has been closed. Each person will
have 3 minutes to address the council.
We ask that everyone remain respectful throughout the hearing.
Disruptive behavior, personal attacks, cheering,
booing, clapping are not permitted.
If this occurs, we'll— you'll be asked to leave the room.
If you've submitted a public comment form online, Lacey will read your name.
To see if you're in attendance to give your comments.
After all comments are submitted, the meeting— in
the meeting have been addressed, we will invite those attending in person to speak first,
followed by those participating online. So Lacey will help us manage
that. Everyone will have a chance to speak if you so desire.
And we'll go in the order that she sets forth with people in
person, the ones submitted online, and then those online.
For those attending virtually, including email,
by the way, for those attending virtually, when the time comes,
uh, Lacey will call your name and will electronically ask you to unmute your microphone.
Your 3-minute speaking time will begin once you start speaking.
You're welcome to remain in the meeting to observe, but you will not be able
to provide additional comment. Everybody gets one chance.
If you prefer, you may continue watching the meeting through the city's
online streaming portal. Please make sure to speak clearly
into the microphone. After all speakers have had the opportunity to comment,
the recorder's office will conduct one final check. We'll check
to make sure everybody's had a chance. If you still feel like you haven't had
a chance to speak, we'll allow one last chance and then we'll close the public
hearing. So, I've read those things again. Order of events,
we're going to start with public comment prior to the meeting, then the participants in
attendance, then the virtual ones. Then email.
Lacey, have you, uh, heard those instructions and do you feel like
there's any clarification needed? I think you hit everything perfectly.
We will go with it as we go, so we're good.
Okay, perfectly. It is 5:07 on the 6th of
August. Correct. Hang on, Mayor. Hang on, Mayor.
Uh, you're in a different time zone. It's— I'm— yeah,
6:07. 6:07, sorry.
At, uh, I look at my clock and that's what told me. So 6:07 on
August 6th, um, and we will now open this
public hearing. So Lacey, I'll turn it to you to call up in order.
Sounds great. We will go ahead and start with John Breeding.
So I went online earlier today and I looked up that since
2020 we've had about a 78% increase in revenues.
We've had a population growth of about 60%.
Inflation's run about 29% since then.
And an 11% increase in taxes would give
an inflation-adjusted equivalent of what
we had for revenue in 2020.
I'm kind of cynical. I believe that a 220%
increase is kind of a head fake
that I don't think anybody here actually believes that
that's what is going to happen.
But when you eventually come up with about a 40%
increase in taxes, which is also outrageous,
people will be less up in arms about it. And I
don't understand why, as government, as our population
grows and as the government grows, that you don't become more efficient
with artificial intelligence and
computers and things like that. It seems like government is the only
thing that doesn't become more efficient with scale.
Anyway, that's my comment.
Chaz Roberts.
I do not see Chaz Roberts in attendance. We will include it into the record.
Melissa Bradley.
I'm disappointed. I'm frustrated. It's not the resident's
job to prevent a tax increase. Mayor, council,
you're supposed to be able to prioritize needs over wants.
I'm against the 220% property tax increase because
it's not for public safety. It's for nonessential projects
that the city can't afford. Let me be clear. I support funding our sheriff's office.
I support paying employees competitive wages. I support needing roads,
water, and sewer improvements, and you already have the money in place do all
of that. This increase is a burden on the average taxpayer.
25.2 million Americans under 35 lived with their
parents last year. That's not normal. And raising our property
taxes is not the solution. You're adding to this crisis.
Craig, Rich, Brett, you all are real estate agents.
You should understand this. Jared, you were the real estate agent. You should
know the consequences. Zach, as an investor, you should get this. Melissa, as a mom
with adults living in your home, I assume you understand. Thank you. Property tax increases
don't stop with homeowners. Landlords will pass those costs
to their renters, and our children and your residents will pay higher rent.
Families will have less money to help their kids with rent,
gasoline, or groceries. As housing costs rise,
which they are unaffordable right now, young adults will stay home longer,
and that delays their independence. Families already caring
for adults, children, grandchildren, or aging parents have
even less room in their budgets when you increase fixed housing
costs. By increasing our property taxes, each one of
you is choosing to negatively impact 26 families in
my neighborhood. In one week, that will be 27 because
my kids are moving in— my adult kids, 2 of them.
When you're proposing what you're proposing is wrong, it's dishonest. When you
claim it's for public safety, it isn't. It's for completely optional
structures like a new city hall and rec center. And the fact that you had
the city manager admit that on Tuesday instead of standing up
and saying it for yourselves is crap. I hope you choose
to lead with honesty moving forward. When you took your oath of
office, you all promised to be faithful stewards of the taxpayer dollar.
The people of Eagle Mountain work hard for each dollar they earn, and they're
making difficult financial decisions every day. We want you
to do the same. We have
contracts in place. And they will benefit our community soon.
Be patient. Focus on public safety, sewer, water,
and roads. 30 seconds remaining. Stop looking to the taxpayers to
solve your pretend budget crisis. We don't believe you.
Go attract businesses to expand the tax business, and you— and
then you better leave residents' sales tax alone.
I caught that in Tuesday's meeting. It is our right to decide When and how
we want to spend our money. Stay out of our pockets. Our community wants freedom
from taxes, not slavery to it. Do not raise property taxes and no new
taxes.
I'm just going to remind you that the mayor gave us clear instructions that we're
not going to entertain that. Clapping was not part of those
instructions. Yes, it was. So we're going to ask
you to refrain from that type of outburst because it's going to delay the opportunity
for those who want to come and speak to us. So please refrain
from that, or according to his instructions, we're going to ask you
I do have Adam Brady for the next one. It does say
my wife Melissa will read the statement. I am unsure if he's here. Adam Bradley.
Sorry, you have to hear from me again. Good evening, Mayor and Council. My name
is Adam Bradley, and I'm here to strongly oppose this proposed 220%
property tax increase. In fact, I believe you should be lowering taxes and
not raising them. A 220% increase is an enormous
ask. Saying it's justified simply because property taxes
haven't been raised in 15 years is an insult to basic math.
This represents real money for families already struggling with inflation,
rising home values, and higher taxes across the board.
Eagle Mountain's explosive growth has already expanded the city's revenue
through impact fees, building permits, and commercial development. So why
isn't that growing paying for these needs? I've seen
no convincing evidence that existing revenue can't fund competitive
wages for our employees, and I've seen no categorical proof that we need
more sheriff deputies. Comparing Eagle Mountain to other cities doesn't
work. There's no other city like Eagle Mountain.
Show me the 911 calls that aren't being answered. Show me domestic
violence calls going unanswered. Show me crimes not being
solved. I haven't seen that evidence. Until a few days ago,
residents were told every dollar of this tax increase would go to public
safety. Then people started doing the math. The sheriff's contract increases
by roughly $1.5 million while this tax hike brings in
about $6.7 million. Order.
Only after residents started asking questions did you admit the
rest is for other projects, including a new city hall.
This was never just about public safety.
I've also heard almost no discussion of alternatives.
Where's the debate? Where are the compromises? One council
member even told my wife to do the research and come back with ideas.
With respect, that's the job that you were elected to do.
When I served on this council, I said no all the time because
protecting taxpayers came first. Growth should be allowing
us to reduce the tax burden, not asking
families to pay more. I'll leave you with this: Have
you forgotten the proper role of city government? This council and
the last have continued to grow government and spending.
What happened to Eagle Mountain being a place that
that valued limited government and respected taxpayers. Please, no more.
Please vote no on this increase and start looking for ways
to lower our property tax instead. And on a personal note,
I would like to add,
I love Adam. 30 seconds remaining. He was a great council member,
and he worked hard.
You're, you're reading his statement, not your own.
You don't get to go twice.
Ben Bracknell.
I don't see Ben Bracknell. Um, it says opposition to proposed
tax increase. Um, I do want to remind those of you online,
uh, for the Zoom link, this is for participating virtually. If you want to watch
the meeting and not participate, you can go to our portal to watch it.
I do have Alex Washburn, uh, for the public comment, but I do see
you're online, so we will call you when the virtual time comes.
Um, Ashley Lauer, or Lower,
um, it only says property tax increase. I do not
see her, but we will add it to the record. Duncan Searcy.
Sorry, I didn't hear the mayor say no clapping. He was quiet,
but I also don't think our First Amendment rights care much about his decorum.
So the title of this meeting is Truth in Taxation
Public Hearing. I want to quote the city. This is what
they said. Eagle Mountain City is proposing a property
tax increase with every dollar going straight to public safety,
period. So that's a lie, and we all
know that now. And so that's not a great way to start this meeting off.
I was a lot nicer on Tuesday when I spoke, but some of the
responses I got from you actually is what made me upset, and I'm not gonna
be quite as nice tonight. You'll see some of the pensioners I mentioned on Tuesday
are here. That's great. Every single one of you, when I brought this up,
expressed remorse, like, we don't wanna be doing this, you know?
This is so hard on our community. This is just a necessary
evil that we have to do. And Brett, you said something
that struck me. You said, we have been called upon. To make this
decision. Brett, who is calling upon you to raise the property taxes
if we elect you and you work for us? I would like to
know after all this is done if you would address that specifically.
Who's calling upon you to make any kind of decision? Okay.
And then Melissa, it bothered you so much, just the thought of raising taxes
on our poor families brought you to tears.
Sweetheart, you don't need to be upset. Just vote no. You don't have to raise
the taxes. This is your choice. you get to vote yes or no.
Okay? So I think we
just need to realize everybody is struggling in this economy,
every single person. Okay? If we as citizens are
tightening our belts and we're deciding what we have to cut out
of our lives, so must the city. Okay? There's money coming
down the pipeline. Mayor Gray preaches about it all the time. So let's—
Thank you. Tighten up our belt as a city instead
of pushing those tax burdens onto the regular person. Okay.
And Melissa, I'm sorry, I'm going to call you out a little bit. I'm tired
of the performative testimony meeting style emotion.
It's manipulative. Okay. And you have the chance tonight
to vote no and prove that I'm wrong and that you really do care about
the poor families. But when you sit up there and get emotional, it really bothers
those of us that have discernment. Okay? A big reason
why we're here tonight is because you gave Meta, a $1.5 trillion
company, a 20-year tax break. Okay?
Had you not done that— 30 seconds remaining. I don't think we'd be in this
financial situation that we're at. And you keep touting this infrastructure
that Facebook has brought to the city. I have never once driven out to the
Facebook building, probably never will. They have not improved anything
in the city that we, the citizens, use on a daily basis.
So stop trying to gaslight us into like, oh,
Facebook has been such a good deal, this is such a good deal. We're tired
of it. Start working for us, or next election we
are going to speak even louder. Your time is up.
Thank you.
Ryan Parker also
does not say— just says property tax increase. I do not see him here,
so we'll add it to the record. Charles Peterson.
Good evening. As a former federal government
program analyst, I have more questions than answers.
So in reviewing all this material,
What I'll give you is some questions.
We've moved here— well, we've been here for 10 years now and so
on. So I've got a number of questions that bother me. A couple of
these things have already been mentioned. Of the $6.9
million, and with $1.5
million for the added police officers,
I would be curious what the analysis was done— sorry,
as an analyst— to say how
do we need that many more? And it's already
been addressed a little bit. Is our
public safety been reduced without these?
I don't know. That's a question that I have.
Second— is
looking at the information that was available, by going and approving
this, we will become the most— I think the second most
property taxed city in Jefferson— I'm sorry,
I'm thinking of my own old county, but in Utah County,
we are now second best. And I was reading
a piece talking about being so wonderful about
how our taxes are low. Now, if this
is approved, we're going to go right up to the top. Excuse me.
The other thing that bothers me as an analyst is
the other— what is it?
About 5. Yeah, 5.4 million goes into
public safety. Now,
is there a fund called public safety?
What happens to that? Is there an outline of all
the things that you're going to do with this $5.4
million? I haven't
seen anything.
So what we would expect as an analyst is to say, okay,
and I've had a lot of dealings with budget analysts.
What are we actually talking about? What are the line items and
what are those results going to be? 30 seconds remaining. I think that's
critical. And if you can't show that, then we ought not to be
voting for it, frankly. Thank you very much.
I do want to clarify that we We do have Ryan Parker online, so we'll
go back to his comment, but he is virtual. Dave Bresheenahan.
Thank you.
Mr. Mayor and City Council, thank you for allowing me the opportunity
to speak. I'm grateful for each
one of you, and I know how tough your job is. I really
do. I wouldn't want to be in your position.
The people that you represent, the people of Eagle Mountain,
which has a median age of 23,
and approximately 44% of our
population are under 18,
which helps us to see this is a community filled with
a lot of young families.
Then there's people over 65, like me.
We only make up about 3% of Eagle Mountain. Young families
are just getting started building careers and do not have a significant
income, with the median individual income of $48,105
per person. The average retired couple
have a combined income of $79,315.
We are all strapped for cash.
The cost of living is making it harder and harder for the
average family to get by. The added proposed tax
adds to that burden and makes life more difficult than it already
is for the vast majority of all these young families.
I got my numbers from Google, by the way.
Eagle Mountain charges an impact fee on new residential and
commercial development. That fee is intended
to fund the expansion of services because of the
impact of that development.
A portion of that impact fee is intended for public safety.
I know about impact fees because I was a
member of the legislature when we voted that into state
law. I go back a ways.
Families, young and old, have a specific income that must be
budgeted to take care of all the expenses for their family.
As the cost of living goes up, families must find ways
to cut corners and tighten the budget, which means shopping
sales, using coupons, using Facebook Marketplace,
and they do without A lot of times in
order to make it all work. 30 seconds remaining. I would suggest
that the city has the mechanism to pay for additional services
that come with the growth of the city through impact fees.
I know developers hate those fees,
but it's a part of the cost of doing business.
And they are making millions in Eagle Mountain. Those impact
fees won't affect their millions. Hopefully,
the city can find ways to become more efficient in the services
that the city provides. I ask the city council to— Your
time is up. Thank you.
Brian Free.
Great to be here today. I want to thank you all for not kicking the
can down the road. Uh, seems like the trend since I've lived here
for 20, 20 years. The can keeps getting kicked down the road so we can
keep our taxes low or whatever, and the needs of our city
continue to grow. We're a growing city. There's needs and they have to be taken
care of. So thank you for that. Um, I, I think that goes a note.
I, I also want to say that a lot of us have probably had a
knee-jerk reaction to, to a 220% increase,
which is actually lower if you add in, you know, your fire and your sheriffs
and put that all together like another city would have in their city tax.
We're probably right in the middle, and then we're probably at the top when we
add 220%. So that's, you know, so that's more of an apples-to-apples comparison,
which is good to do. I think one of the issues is there wasn't a
lot of transparency, right? So we're not seeing what you guys are seeing, and that
may not necessarily be right on you, but on those who were tasked
with putting out information for us. Um, we like to see what all those— we
like to know that it's not 100% for one thing, one portion, that it's for
a bunch of things that are all needs within our city. And, and seeing those
line items is really helpful so we can see exactly what it's paid for.
There may be a lot of us that would say I don't like it,
but those are all needs. I don't know how we don't take care of them.
And if we saw what each of those things are, right, and maybe we'd have
some different, different type of discussion because we would all come more informed without
having to dig deep to try to find those answers. On our own and do
that work that could easily be provided for us because you guys already
have it, some of that information. So that would be very helpful for us to
see what those line items are. I will say that in
addition, one of the things that we want to make sure we're doing is that
we're taking advantage of looking at the things that, let's say my basement's
flooding, I got to get that water shut off and get that water out of
there and clean everything up or I'm going to lose my home, right? Those are
the kind of things we need to take care of. And I know we have
some of those kinds of issues. In our city that need to be addressed that
maybe we don't always see day to day as residents. And so that's important.
Um, but 220% or the lower number, if we include everything together,
whatever that percent is, it's still an increase. It's still a tax,
um, with everything else like has been mentioned that, that we're seeing increase in
our lives. And we want to make sure that that's being— um, we're looking
at zero. Let's say we can't do anything, zero, without going into major
debt to do it. And then add to that, well, what can we do?
And then what can we do in 2, 3 years when some of that data
center money starts coming off? Like, when they first were talking about data centers,
we were told whatever the size is, one data center is like 4 or 5
Costcos or Walmarts worth of revenue. That's a lot of revenue.
If that starts coming on board in a couple years, we've got a lot of
revenue coming our way, right? So we'll be able to— we should be able to
then reduce taxes. 30 seconds remaining. But one thing I'll leave you with,
just because it's a buzz term, let's not
California our Utah. A 220% increase is
a California in our Utah. And that's something I don't think any of you want
to do or any of you are in favor of. Most of you would consider
yourself conservative, fiscally conservative, and I would hope that you'll really take that into consideration.
Thank you. Matt Oakman.
I don't see him online and I don't see him in person. We'll add him
to the record. Matthew Endicott.
My name is Matt Endicott, and I've lived in Eagle Mountain for about 6 years.
I've listened to the presentation given by Chief Deputy Knutson in April, as well as
the comments I've received from the city council in response to my email this week.
Um, thank you for your responses. Um, but I seem to have missed some important
discussion in Tuesday's meeting. Um, I'll have to go back and review that.
After reviewing of the budget that was released earlier this week, this issue has been
made clear. The messaging from the mayor was confusing and may have led to the
level of negative responses being voiced, but after review, I have a couple of questions.
Based on my review, the proposed public safety budget is about $10 million,
which is, you know, based off of other things, which is about $2 million higher
than last year. This revenue from property taxes
last year covered about 50% of the previous costs,
with the other 50% coming from the general fund. So sales tax or
other things, if I understand that correctly. So I have a couple questions. Why is
it necessary for the entire amount of the sheriff's contract to be covered by revenue
from property taxes? Was revenue from the other sources projected to fall
below the needed amount to cover the contract amount, or are there
other budget areas that need a roughly $4 million increase and this tax hike is
being done under the guise of public safety because that is an easier sell than
other programs? With this switch from using the general
fund along with property taxes to only
using property taxes for the sheriff, will the general fund be reduced
a proportionate amount to reflect the change, or is the city— total city budget
raising the $6 million? With the increase in sheriff
deputies, is there any changes to the contract to make sure we are being protected
and that the increased presence won't be used for generating revenue through tickets or over-policing
as seen in neighborhood cities such as Saratoga Springs and American Fork? I understand,
but have my disagreements with, the comments made by the Sheriff's Office and the City
Council that Eagle Mountain could use a larger police force. I also understand there
has not been a property tax hike in Eagle Mountain for a number of years.
These 2 things being understood, why did the City Council feel the need to swap
100% of the costs, including the $2 million increase, in one year?
Could it not be possible to continue using alternative revenue sources for the Sheriff's Office
with a modest increase to property taxes to cover the $2 million increase?
Why was there the need to switch the entire $10 million over to property taxes?
This seems— this just seems to me, and I imagine a number of folks here,
a dramatic increase to the size and scope of the city under the guise of
public safety to avoid having to have discussion or try and sell a less popular
budget item. Thank you.
Andrew Burke.
My name's Andrew Burke. I've been here a couple times, a couple years back,
like 5 years ago, and then recently moved here after we built our home last
year. I'm gonna make this short. I do agree that the police
office, the Sheriff's Department has to be supported. I do believe that, you know,
we do need to, based off the research that I've done, we do need to
increase it 0.45 over 1,000 residents versus
the average of about 0.8. I mean, some of the stuff the chief deputy said
wasn't accurate, like Saratoga's at 1.56 per thousand,
but I'm not going to go into the semantics. Um, I do agree with the
previous speaker that I don't think that the property taxes should be
the thing that's covering all the increases.
And I think my biggest issue, and I think most people would agree,
is that the transparency is just not there. Why can't you give
us— if you've allotted a certain amount for improvements
under the guise of public safety, why can't
you give us an itemized report before you say, yeah, we're voting on this?
Let us know what you're increasing.
So, I mean, it's frustrating because everybody is
struggling. It's harder. Like, I heard a comment about AI. A lot
of us don't know if we're going to have jobs in 2 years. Because AI
is taking away the workforce. And,
you know, now to sit there and say, hey, 220% right now,
we haven't done it in 15 years, right now, without gradually
rolling it out, it's almost criminal.
Like, why would you— why would you do that to us? You were—
we voted for you, and this is how you repay us?
Now, I'm not against Increasing the budget for our sheriffs.
Public— that is public safety. But $6.7,
almost $8 million increased with no itemized budget?
That's not acceptable.
So my question is, if you are going to do this, can we get an
itemized line for line on how every dollar is going to be spent?
Because if you're not going to do that, then don't pass the bill.
That's my time.
Kelly Horton?
I don't see Kelly. Can I take his time?
I'm not on the list. You can— Can I take her time?
You can fill out a paper. I'm right here. Oh, you're there. Oh, I'm sorry.
No worries. It's all right,
you can take your own time. My name is Kelly
Horton. I've been here since 2016. You know, I first want
to begin by saying that, you know, we really do support our public safety
here. We love our law enforcement out here. I don't think anybody's going to disagree
with that. Our firefighters, first responders, everything they do
every day. It's not about whether they deserve support. They absolutely do.
I said this is about whether asking residents to shoulder such a substantial
tax increases the only or the best solution.
Many of us are already struggling. The cost of groceries,
utilities, insurance, and housing has increased dramatically.
Families are making difficult choices every month just to stay afloat.
For people living on fixed incomes, seniors, and residents with disabilities,
even a few hundred dollars a year can make the difference between paying bills and
falling behind. You know, before asking taxpayers to pay more, I respectfully ask,
You know, what specific spending reductions were made before deciding
to raise taxes? You know, what programs or projects were delayed or
eliminated to demonstrate that every other option has been exhausted?
You know, why is the increase— this increase being proposed all at once
instead of being phased in over several years? You know, what guarantees
can you provide that this won't become the new normal with additional
large increases in the future? How will the city measure whether
these additional tax dollars actually improve public safety,
and will those results be reported publicly?
Transparency matters. Residents deserve to know exactly
where every additional dollar will go, how success will
be measured, and what accountability exists if the
expected results are not achieved. You know, Eagle Mountain has grown rapidly.
That growth has brought challenges, but it's also brought additional homes,
businesses, and a broader tax base. I ask that the council
to, to please explain what that growth alone— why that growth
alone is not enough to help meet these needs. And most importantly,
please remember that behind every tax bill is a family. You know,
for, for some, this may seem like a budget decision, but for
residents, it's groceries, it's medicine, it's gas, it's schools,
clothes, it's child care, or keeping a roof over our heads.
You know, I respectfully ask the council to reconsider the size and timing
of this increase. If additional funding is truly necessary,
consider a phased approach. Continue identifying spending
efficiencies and ensure residents are fully informed before placing a greater
financial burden on them. Thank you for your time.
Anthony Wood.
My name is Anthony. Um,
so true, true representation means reflecting the will of your constituents.
When you must convince us of your narrative, then that's manipulation.
The tax increase is being advertised as a need for increase in
law enforcement. The supporting stats that are being used are how many
officers there are per 1,000 citizens.
I don't like that. I don't like that number. What I do think we should
be looking at is the crime rates. So if we're using some of the comparative
cities you guys were using in the— in the how many officers per capita,
Sandy is 32 in 1,000. Means you're going to be— you have
a chance of being a victim 32 times out
of 1,000. For Lehigh, it's 22 per 1,000. Do you
guys have any idea what Eagle Mountain is? It is 1 to 1.2
per 1,000. Our crime rate is very low.
We see our officers, multiple vehicles per stop.
That's what we get to see as citizens. 4— 3 squad cars,
4 squad cars per stop, per incident. We see
them at the gas stations. It doesn't look like they're crazy busy. Right.
They may need some support, but this is the wrong way to go about it.
You're asking the wrong people to pay for this.
What I mean is that there are a lot of corporations, like we were talking
about with the data centers, that are getting those tax breaks.
They do a lot of damage to our infrastructure, our water, our roads,
and they're not contributing to that. I was looking at the repairs to Pony Express,
and it took us the end of '24 and '25
to finish Pony Express, and I went on there the very next day and I
rode it. I ride a motorcycle and I rode it. It's garbage.
I don't know how much you guys spent on that, but it's trash. It needs
to be done again. Who signed off in saying that that was okay?
Another example about the spending, and like, I would like to
focus on budgeting what we have first before
we ask for more. And another example that I have concerns with,
with how we spend our money is that in 2022, in August, we spent—
we sent $1.13 million
to a scammer. Just money gone. Like, we need to budget what we
have before we ask for more. I agree, we may need more,
but I need to focus on the budget before we get there. I mean,
I don't lend money to family members and friends that are irresponsible
with money, and I don't want to do the same thing here. Can you say
that again? I don't want to give you more money. I don't trust you guys
with it. I mean, sending money to a scammer, I have to teach my grandma
not to do that. I don't want to have to teach you guys not to
That's all I have.
Bruno Hunsaker.
I don't know about following all these guys that's been up here.
Some great comments.
I'm just going to represent the old guys or the old
women. We're the seniors. So most people on Social
Security, the average, like Brett's mom, is probably $1,300 or $1,400
a month because she's been on it. I'm about $1,800,
so I'm a little more fortunate. So I give you $300 extra.
And so— and we're on a fixed income. I'm lucky
I still work part-time, so it's not going to affect me as much. But these
young families that they've all been talking about.
So we get $300 there. And those of you that don't know what's going to
happen next year when this mighty new school district comes
in that you were all buffaloed into voting for,
they're going to start out $200 million in the hole. So if
you think the City Council is going to charge you $300
more on a $500,000 home, you wait till next year's
tax intrication when the district is going to raise that
up probably $300 to $400 plus a bond the next year.
They need 17 schools in the next 15 years,
and they're a pretty small school district to do that. So I'm just telling you,
I hope you all show up next year in total force when
that school board meets to increase your taxes.
And also, I agree on some of those roads because I ride
a bike too, and It's supposed to be a soft tail, but it really is
a hard tail on that road. So anyway,
I support law enforcement. I don't know what the crime rate
is. I'm thinking per capita,
it might be as bad as West Valley City because all I ever hear is
domestic this and domestic that. They're doing their job,
and I know they need an increase. Thank you. But like everybody else said,
how many building permits? We had the most building permits in the state
of Utah in Eagle Mountain last year. And then I see them build
2 homes over by Blackridge, and they brought gravel
in, compacted a little bit, and put these 2 new homes in just
to get a building permit. I'm starting to wonder if people will sell somebody in
their family for a building permit.
Just that much— those building permits and those impact fees should
be paying for what you're asking for. I know your minds
are made up. I don't think you're going to budge. I think it's going to
go through, and I know you feel our pain.
So anyway, 30 seconds remaining. I appreciate the job you guys are doing,
and I know it's a hard job, but I'm just telling people you're going to
be paying a lot of money the next 3 years between this and the new
school district. And the mayor tells me while he was a city councilman
the water treatment plant needs to be updated next 4 years, there's another $50
a month on top of that. Thank you.
Nathan Thornburg.
Hello, I'm Nathan Thornburg.
Um, I can understand the way the state tax
regulations and codes don't
help increase revenue as property values
increase.
However, like everybody else, I have questions.
Why wasn't— why was the campaign
initially, that was initially released,
that This is gonna 100%
be to increase our public safety.
The end. Period. And we were all,
I think the way that the messaging was presented was we were all supposed
to go, yes, yes.
And it was only after members of our community actually
pressed that there was more of an explanation
given. This is going to free up money so that we can better
improve things. I think we all would have loved to hear
that initially, if money
was— if there was a plan to increase revenue
to improve the
quality of life here in Eagle Mountain, you wouldn't be
getting slammed right now. You probably still
would be because 220%, as was stated earlier
is almost criminal.
Do you see how the changing of the narrative only after
being pressed erodes trust? Now we don't know what to believe.
You were either dishonest then or you're dishonest now.
Anything you say to smooth it over can at best only
be taken with a grain of salt. But most likely
is just not going to be believed at all unless
you start putting the actual money where your mouth is.
I think it's safe to say that after tonight you have an assignment.
What's the plan? Is there a proposed budget or schedule of
these capital projects, uh, that the city intends to
complete? And the only way to regain trust in this communities to follow through
with what we need. And if there
is no publicly released budget for us— 30
seconds remaining. —to have access to so that we can, you know,
maybe see— begin to see some
of your intentions, if that isn't released to us,
what are we left to believe? Are we supposed to just
trust you? We don't trust you. If there is no
line item given to us,
what are we left with?
Your time is up. Thank you. Matt Everett.
Good evening, Council. Good evening, Mayor, wherever you are.
I Um, stand to, uh,
stand firmly in the minority opinion of the people that are in this room tonight.
Um, I encourage you to pass this tax increase.
Now, having said that, 220% is a big
number. I wish it wasn't that big. I, knowing you and
the interactions that I've had, I would assume that you probably have a similar
feeling to that. In my opinion, 220% is a direct
reflection of poor management and leadership that
the city has had in the past 15-plus years. My family
and I have lived in the city for about 17, a little over 17 years.
I've raised my family here. I'm continuing to raise my family here.
There are a lot of things that need to be improved in the city.
Talk about roads. We've talked about infrastructure. We've talked about a lot of different things.
All of those things cost money. And there's limited ways that
the city's able to— Your actions— To take care of those needs and
the requirements that they have. Moving the property
taxes and using this increase to fund public safety
makes it a stable fund that we're able— the city will be able to
use those known dollars every year to fund the
needs of the public safety.
So this is a difficult night. This is gonna
be a difficult thing for a lot of residents. I understand that. But I encourage
you to continue on the path of leadership that
you have and to make the hard decisions regardless
of what the outcomes of those will be. Thank you.
Mark McConkey.
Others have talked about their frustration that these funds aren't being— aren't
actually being used for public safety, and I feel that pain, especially as the funds
we use for public safety now get sent out of the— out to the county
rather than being used to establish our own public safety through a city police department
accountable to the mayor and this council. Eagle Mountain is the largest city in Utah
without its own dedicated city police department. And looking
at the state's border in Utah, we're the second largest city without a police department.
Only Centennial in Colorado is bigger. In fact, if we were
to take a deeper dive on this and take a look at the size of
the largest cities in each of the states without a police department, here's what we'd
see. Eagle Mountain is twice the size of Kuna, Idaho, their largest city.
We're 3 times larger than Fernley, Nevada, their largest city without a
police department. We're 4.6 times larger than Castle Pines, Colorado,
which is their second after Centennial. We're 3.1 times
larger than Fountain Hills, Arizona, and we're a whopping 37.8 times
larger than Pinedale, Wyoming, which is their largest city without a city
police department. We've outgrown the point where we should rely on, on county support rather
than owning that ourselves. Every dollar that we send to the county for policing is
a dollar that we give to be controlled by the county, and every decision about
how our streets are patrolled is made by people who don't answer to this council
or to the residents of Eagle Mountain. Right now, as we contract with the county
sheriff, that means we have no direct say over hiring standards, use of force policy,
response priorities, or community policing style.
Those decisions are made for the whole county and are not tailored to us.
If we ever disagree with those decisions, we don't have the ability to push for
those changes outside of election season. Even during election season, Eagle Mountain
only accounts for 10% of the voter population in Utah County, and there may well
be some elections where where the sheriff runs unopposed, as he is this
year, which limits our options even more. A city police chief would
answer to the mayor and to this council and its residents, getting a clear line
of accountability. I know the first objection is going to be cost, especially startup
costs, but the city already owns the building the sheriff's department operates out of right
here in Eagle Mountain. If we convert that city to a police department, there's no
new facility building or lease. That overhead already exists.
Because our contract with the county sheriff's department accounts for about 1/3 of their budget,
likely be able to transition many of their officers to city officer positions
as well, reducing costs of hiring and training. We're not building departments from
scratch, we're being able to convert what's already here. Beyond that, the startup
and transition costs will only be higher in the future as our population grows.
When it comes to our policing options, I see 3 options:
start a police department now, start a police department sometime in the future— 30 seconds
remaining. —as our population grows, or never start a police department and
be okay with not having control over our police force. So my ask
tonight is to conduct a study of the cost for standing up a municipal police
department. As we earmark these funds for public safety, let's use these funds in
a way that we can control. Thank you.
Betty Peralta.
Good evening. My name is Betty Peralta,
and I'm here to oppose the increase, and these
are comments I have. The proposed
increase, I feel, is outrageous. The justification is not
clear enough. The homeowner property rates increase,
and as our income remains the same. The property
values, especially in my community, which is Sweetwater,
continue to fall. Eagle Mountain city center and communities
look more run-down every day.
My property value alone has decreased $7,000 in 2 months.
So yes, I agree with the previous speakers that
this is criminal to impose a tax rate
increase of this kind. The traffic has increased here significantly.
The roads are horrible. And the
majority of homeowners, I'm asking to oppose this increase.
And my other question is, because it has not been outright
and truthful what these funds are being used for, are we using any
of these funds for city council staff pay increases?
I'm all in for safety and first responders. I'm a retired
38-year first responder, so I know that those are essential
and necessary needs for Eagle Mountain, but I cannot justify the
increase. Thank you.
Joseph Pill— I don't know how to say it.
Not even close. Thank you. It's French. Not even close.
First of all, I just wanna say— I'm sorry, hold on, Joseph, will you say
it for the record? Oh, Joseph Pedlow.
All right, so first I wanna say I don't wanna be being in your seats
tonight. It's probably not a fun meeting. But I
do wanna thank you for your service and the commitments, 'cause you wouldn't have run
for this position if you didn't want it. The big thing I wanna say is
just urging caution. So I work in higher education
in the state, and I've worked there for about 10 years. And over those times,
we've seen again and again when the state legislature has proposed big budget increases
and big budget pushes, and there'll be community blowup and hard feelings,
and often it gets redacted. And I think we can learn a lesson from that.
I don't think anyone here doesn't want to help our officers. We do.
We want them to be the best officers in the county. We want them to
have the resources they need. But I think we also can all
agree that 220% is a lot at once, especially since a lot of us are
nervous about the new school district. about water facilities, road infrastructure,
more infrastructure as the city grows. We're one of the fastest growing cities in Utah.
So my hope would be just to urge caution because we don't
know what it's going to be like in 3 years. We don't know if the
new school district is going to ask for a 300% increase because they don't have
administrative buildings, they don't have a bus depot, they don't have the mechanics. We don't
know that. We don't know what the water will be. We don't know what the
infrastructure will be. And we do know we are getting more stores. We're getting Lowe's.
We're getting Smith's, and we will see that income increase as the hospital
comes out here and as other plans happen. But we just don't know what that
is right now. But we do know 220% is a lot to
ask, especially since transparency has been an issue for a lot of residents.
So my only advice is just caution, because maybe this is
where we do need to be, and maybe you have very important reasons. I believe
you're all amazing people who aren't increasing this for no reason. Thank you.
But we can all agree that this is a bit of a shock in the
community, and you probably don't have this typical turnout at events like this because
we're shocked at the number, and we're shocked at the fact that we don't know
exactly what the general fund that's gonna be increasing by about $5 million,
what's that meant for? So my only advice is just to urge
caution, maybe do a smaller increase. Let us see what the new revenues will
be when we get more infrastructure. Let's see what the new property value revenues will
be. Let us see what the store of news will be, and then let us
know what we need to do. Because I think no one here is opposed to
bettering our city and bettering our police force. I think what we are opposed
to is making a jump in the dark. So thank you.
Josh Shadd.
My name is Josh Shadd. I've been a resident here for about 12 years.
Really came to me as a shock that you guys are going to increase the
taxes by 220%. So I just have some comments I wrote
down. With the increased tax revenue that will be added to the general fund and
used for capital projects, it's a little deceitful to present, present this
as 100% funding towards public safety, as the previously allocated
funds are now set into the general fund and used for capital projects.
As we build out housing in Eagle Mountain, property taxes should increase,
and Why haven't those funds been properly allocated in the budget?
And just to clarify, I don't have any issue with increasing policing,
police presence within the city limits of Eagle Mountain. The issue I have is the
communication of this city council to its members, to the residents
of Eagle Mountain, and being clear with your guys' intention of what you
intend to do with our tax dollars. This is something that I have brought
up before, is communication from this city hall. The city hall is terrible
at messaging. You guys are terrible at communicating meetings.
You guys are terrible at reaching out to the citizens.
The only reason I saw this is because I happen to go on Facebook.
I've signed up for all your newsletters, all your text messages. I go on the
website every once in a while, but I have a life outside of this city,
so you guys need to be better at messaging.
Previous city councils have also failed to to take— to be
good stewards of our taxpayer dollars. Convince us that this
tax increase for the taxpayers is going
to not be wasted and misallocated
and spent on things that are not in the budget or are hidden
or moved to the side. On another note, I do believe
we have had a utility rate increase that's supposed
to happen over the next couple years, and that is in addition
to this. So you guys are going to be putting undue stress on the normal
families of Eagle Mountain. And I think that's pretty
much it I got. Thank you guys for your time.
Mark Espinoza.
Council,
Thank you for having this meeting. Sure, big turnout here. I hear a lot of
people concerned. My big concern is,
guys, I, I had a business,
made a payroll and stuff. All the things that you
need to do to run a business, you got to make. But guys,
220% increase? If I did that to my customers, I'd be out
of business. So we got to do something. Everybody's so fed
up that 220%— if it's
3%, you would have had half a crowd in here. But you go to— you
hit it big, 220%. Maybe go back.
I don't know if we have time or if you're going to vote on this.
If you're going to vote on this tonight, we're pretty much, pretty much done.
You got to go back and look. How can we bring up revenue?
I hope the mayor is doing something. I wish he was here instead
of thinking that he's looking at a video on Zoom. I wish he was in
front of us looking at all these people here. But if he's making a
great deal for Eagle Mountain, fantastic.
He's got my approval. But I don't think so.
It's important. You got a lot of people here, a lot
of things, especially out here on the communication with you guys. Thank you.
Go on your website, put a link on there, and then it— line
item be— line item. It'll show everybody what's going
on. But again, bringing out
the 220— come on, guys. You know
better. I heard some people here in businesses.
Shoot, you do that to your customers and see how long you're in business.
Again, I heard fixed
incomes and stuff. I came from California,
a lot worse. They don't even listen. It got so bad, I had
to move. I'm glad I moved to Eagle Mountain.
I love the place. Family-oriented, love it.
But do not, do not go down that road. There's a
reason why people move out of California. It's not the poor
people. It's the rich people. People with money,
and they come in to spend the money.
Keep them in Eagle Mountain. That's one way to get the revenue. Other ways,
get some bigger people in businesses. That's how you generate
money into the coffers. Again, I thank
you guys. 30 seconds remaining. I thank you guys for listening to us,
but I hope, I really hope you hear everybody, what they had to say.
I'm retired. I can come up here. I was ticked off working
30 years, buying a business, ticked off. I couldn't go to these meetings.
Shoot, 13, 14 hours a day.
Well, now I'm retired. I could do some more. Thank you
again, and thanks for everybody coming out. Be sure
to vote. Be sure to vote. Thank you. Your time is
up. Thank you. Jeff Ruth.
Hey, counsel. Jared. I'm going to be
the ad bono, aside from Matt, I think. But I'm
a little frustrated because this is going to impact me.
But I can't tell you how many times I've called for an officer and
they don't show up. Yeah, it was kind of minor on the list of things
that were probably going on, but they didn't show up. Once in
a while I get a call and say, hey, we're sorry, you know, we didn't
make it. But We had this
going on. Okay, that's fine. I've called for other things.
Hey, we only got 2 officers on duty this morning.
We can't come out right now. All right,
fine. I've asked, why don't
the officers out here do preventative? We can only do
reactive. We don't have enough officers to do Preventative
calls. I can't tell you all the vandalism I've seen
over at Corey Ride. I mean, it's ridiculous.
Every once in a while, an officer should be sitting out there and catch some
of these teens out there busting things up, busting up
the bathrooms and everything else. And I understand
you're going to shift the money for the officers into
their kind of their own separate account. And that's going to free up other
money. How many times have I been up here and asked you guys to mow
along the roads, to fix this, to fix that?
Well, it's my understanding that if you move the money,
then you'll have the money to do this other stuff.
I mean, it's like with the voles at the park.
Max, I think, got hurt because he— his leg went into one of those holes.
I've asked it to be addressed. Never,
never done. Um, so I mean,
I love our officers. I met many of them. I've dealt with them, and they're
good. I think we need this. Like I said, it's going to impact me
a lot. I'm on Social Security. It's going to be tough.
Me and Melissa talked, I think it was at the convention, about this,
and I understand. Thank you. It's just—
but it gets me. People say, well, bring in more businesses.
Every time a big business wants to come in here,
what do you get? You can't bring that in here.
Oh, it's going to use too much water, too much electricity, this and that.
It just drives me crazy. 30 seconds remaining. Um,
so like I said, how many people here
would vote for a rec center even if it was 300%?
So I hope you pass this. Get us some officers out there to
help us out. Thank you.
Denver Dorrell.
Hi. I didn't come up here prepared.
Life, liberty, and pursuit of happiness. The American dream.
That's what I've always wanted. Eagle Mountain was
the first place I was able to actually achieve that.
And I'm gonna tell you right now, I'm stressed out, panicked,
because that American dream is about to turn into a nightmare.
I am in a single Income household.
Yeah, I make good money, but, you know, I got
everything else going on. Um, I don't think anybody here would argue
setting money aside for the Sheriff's Department, first responders,
because, you know, my family alone has benefited so much
from them. You know, with my 4-year-old daughter who has more flight hours
in a Life Flight than the pilot himself.
My son, who was shot in his neck, you know, right before
Christmas, one of the sheriff's deputies stuck her
finger in my son's neck to keep him from
bleeding out. We ain't got no problem with
setting money aside for the sheriff's department or first responders.
But That, you know,
coming at us, you know, hey, we're going to increase taxes 5, 10,
15%. You know, we can understand
that. But 220%?
I'm living off of credit cards.
I'm sure there's a lot of other families that are doing the same. Fixed incomes,
single-income household. This is going
to break me. I won't be able to afford it.
And we ended up getting kicked out of American Homes
for Rent because of the incident with my son, even though we
had no idea, you know, we couldn't prevent that. That was
an incident that came from a whole other town.
Yeah, we got kicked out, and by the grace of God, he gave
us our own home to move into. But now that's about to be taken
away, and I ain't got nowhere else to go.
So I hope that y'all don't have your minds already set
up on approving this, because it's going to put not
only me and my family, but I'm sure a lot of other families out.
30 seconds remaining. Thank y'all for listening.
Mark Cookston. Cookston.
Good evening, and thank you, uh, City Council and
everybody that works for the city. This is— I wouldn't want to be in your
chair. This is going to be very, very difficult for, for you
as, as it is for for all of us.
In 2018, I was in the
hospital for 5 weeks and life-flighted down to the University of Utah. I lost my
pancreas and automatically became diabetic
and automatically became tied to Utah.
We— I was life-flighted down from Idaho,
and because of that, we have to We
have to live down here in— or I should say we get to live
down here in Utah. We chose
Eagle Mountain because my wife and I grew up in small
towns in Idaho and liked the small-town values.
And we saw that in Eagle Mountain.
We moved in, you know, 5 years ago this coming Thanksgiving.
And we had just passed 40,000 people here. Now we're
closing in on 80,000 people. We liked
the vibe of the community. I will
say that never in my lifetime did I ever think that I would ever be
purchasing a home for half a million dollars.
But coming from Idaho and, you know, coming to
Utah was an eye-opening experience.
We chose Eagle Mountain because it was affordable. We were told
by the previous mayor and then Councilman Gray that,
oh no, we won't have to raise taxes because we've got large
companies that are going to be paying a
large, or footing a large part of
the taxes down the road. Little did I know that
down the road is 20 years, long after I'll be dead.
So that really— that argument was kind of a moot
point for us. I'm on Social Security.
Last year I got a raise of $27 a month.
My God, I thought the rainbow had fallen
upon my house.
Then the county of Utah raised
my taxes $250 last year. 30 seconds remaining. And that was
all gone. This year we've got
this one that is proposed. It's going to be wiped out.
Whatever increase that I, that I get is going to be wiped out.
What am I supposed to do? Where am I supposed to
go? This was the most affordable place for us to live.
I'm here, health reasons, guys.
Where am I supposed to go? What am I supposed to do?
Tighten my belt, I was told. Your time is up. Thank you.
Have you guys tightened your belt?
Tracy Perretta.
All righty.
This isn't
my first meeting. You all know we've come to these meetings and
there's been literally nobody here. It's an absolute ghost town. Okay,
you guys all fit in this City Hall perfectly.
You don't need this one time you go to raise taxes and we get
people in here for a meeting. You are fine in
the building you're in. You don't need to build the new, uh, what do you
call it, in— it's the new,
new base camp on the city
page you did back in March of '25. You put
up all these plans of everything you guys want to build and spend money on.
I don't know where you're getting this money, but it shouldn't be from taxes.
Because I came here and I sat right over there in
a meeting and I opposed the new data center going in, the QST.
And I was told by you, Melissa, personally, and Jared, both told
me afterward, oh, this is such a great thing. The reason we're passing this
is because our taxes are going to go down. They're going to be so low
with all the revenue we're going to get from the data centers coming in
that your taxes are going to go to almost zero. Explain that to
me personally, Melissa, because I will spend the rest of my time getting you out
of office because you lied to me. Same for Jared. If,
if our taxes don't go down to almost zero, why are you
raising them so high? We don't need a rec center.
You know, the last thing you need to do is when money is tight is
say, oh, I need to add on to my house because I get a big
group of people at Christmas. It's not logical.
You've got to spend your money wisely. When everybody
here is tightening their budgets, you guys are building
new Eagle Mountain city signs because the rocks were
deteriorating. You know, I left one weekend,
came back, and I noticed you put up new street signs. What was that price?
$10,000. Your new street signs that you put up were a
total of— I mean, the city mount— Eagle Mountain City sign out there
at Cory Bee Ride, that was probably a $200,000
project or more. You put in
a new set of signs that were on that
page. It says that they were wayfinding sign project to
have Eagle Mountain and make it more cohesive with their signage.
And that was $50,000.
If you tighten your budget everywhere like every single other family has to,
you could make up the money you need for the police and the
fire department. 30 seconds remaining. You don't need to take our taxes and
raise them for something that is just frivolous.
We don't need a rec center. We don't need a new town city
hall. Tighten your budget and figure it out.
'Cause I was told that taxes are going to go down with all the new
data centers, and that's not what you're doing.
Thank you.
Steve Pereda.
Hi, welcome. Thanks for hearing me.
My wife just got done speaking about the data centers. I'm going
to speak about them too. We spoke about them about a year ago.
We took the math of what the tax revenue was going to be. We divided
it by the number of households in Eagle Mountain, and we came up with about
$50 a month towards each household throughout the city of
Eagle Mountain. So $50 a month
is $600 a year. Now you're proposing a 220% increase
that by your own documentation says around $314 a
year increase. So we have a $900-plus
differentiation in what your word was a
year ago because, well, oh, we,
we need to, we need to allow the data centers. The data centers are good
because they're going to bring all this tax revenue in and it's going to reduce
your taxes. A year later were $900 the
other direction? I'd love to see somebody's math
on that as to how that math got screwed up.
So unless you guys fix this— I mean, this was prior to the mayoral race—
all of these people are— the vast
majority of these people, I won't say all, are pretty unhappy.
So when unhappy people go to the voting booths,
All of you get to go find new jobs.
Okay?
If my home budget was short, the first
thing I'd do as a conservative is I'd figure out how to reduce my spending.
I don't just go figure out where I can get more money.
There's also been talk of no transparency. You guys are not giving us
all of the information. Nope, just trust us.
But then your stories are changing, so how can we trust you?
That doesn't work. Inconsistent statements. We need to
itemize budget. We need to quit spending money like drunken sailors on
a port call, okay? Um, running out and, and,
you know, buying signs. Uh, oh,
let's get a rec center. Let's, let's build a new city hall.
What's wrong with this one?
Instead of looking at the entire budget and making educated,
informed decisions, you guys are taking the easy way out.
That's the bottom line. Where's the easy money we can get?
All we have to do is increase our property taxes by 220% and
we can cover all these other expenses we want to do. Please continue.
You were elected to make hard decisions. Make those
hard decisions. Thank you.
Charlotte Dukos.
Charlotte Dukos. I'm going to join Jeff
and Matt in making some comments
that are maybe a little bit different. I've lived here for 26 years. Years and
been involved in the city for the majority of that time,
if not all of it. And over— for
the last over a year, I've attended almost all city council
meetings, missed a couple for other things.
And in attending those meetings, there's a lot of
the questions that are being presented here tonight that have been answered,
and I want to acknowledge that. The budget is online,
line item, in a 200-page document.
And so that is available. All of these projects,
everything that we're talking about tonight has been talked about in city meetings. And so
I want to thank you for actually having those discussions in public meetings
for those that were there. Eagle Mountain
has run lean since its beginning. We have employees doing
the job of 2 to 3 people, probably more in some cases.
We have offices renting space all over the city because they don't fit in this
one. We have projects that we have funded but don't
have personnel to complete, and so they stay undone. We have
complaints all over the city of things that are not maintained,
things that have been promised but have not been done,
and we don't have the personnel to complete it because
we don't have the money to pay them. And We have
waited too long to address these shortfalls. They should have been
addressed years ago in a graduated
manner, a little at a time, but that did not
happen. And we can't keep kicking the can down the road.
At some point, something has to be done, and I applaud you for taking
the time to do that now. That having been said,
I do think the communication could probably have improved. I think most
of you agree with that now as well.
And I do think that a more moderate
approach would be good. It's not too late to do that, and I think
a smaller percentage might be good. I don't think it's going to be a percentage
that most people like. I still think it needs to be a significant one,
but maybe not 220. We would go from being
one of the lowest tax rates in
the area to the 3rd highest. And I think that maybe something
a little more moderate would be a good way to start. And maybe we decrease
that amount a little bit. 30 seconds remaining. I also would encourage
you to put a policy in place that I do not believe is existing right
now where we review this yearly or every other year and
do graduated increases as they are needed. We need to stop being afraid to
balance our budget on a yearly basis so
that these big jumps don't have to happen. And that is my— the conclusion of
my comments. Thank you so much. much for your service.
Michael Valentini.
Hello, my name is Michael Valentini.
I moved out here almost 2 years ago to the date. Um, we moved
out here because it, uh, gave us an opportunity that
we didn't have in Lehi for our children. Uh, One thing
I'd like to say is that the data centers,
my question for you is what tax breaks did the data centers
get? So I've been a union member of Local 140 Plumbers and
Pipefitters here in Utah for 29 years.
I work at the data centers. I've worked at Facebook and QTS
since 2000. Okay, that's my question.
QTS has 3 buildings going on now.
A 4th is being built now. The 5th is coming.
From what I understand, there'll be 6 additional buildings at QTS.
Facebook has 5 buildings now, the 3
ECO— or the 3 original buildings,
2 additional buildings that went in just previously,
and they are building 2 more buildings out there now. So what
tax breaks do they get? As more people
come in building these, that brings revenue into the
economy. Am I wrong to say that there's
6,000, 4,000 to 6,000 construction workers between Facebook
and QTS building those facilities? They bring money into this community every day
at the gas stations, the grocery stores, everything.
So that generates money for this community.
Okay, we do need to have police, a police force out here, the first
responders. Those are very important, but we also need
to be able to live. There are a lot of communities that are being built
in here that have, what do they call them, the ADUs, apartments in
the basements. So that shows that people that are buying these houses
are supplementing income by having renters in
their basements. Okay, what's the average income
of of Eagle Mountain, 78,000? What's the average
cost of a house? What's the average cost of that house? And then
you want to increase our taxes by 220%.
So if we haven't had a tax increase on
our property tax in 10 or 15 years,
why wasn't this budgeted in at 5%,
2% a year over the last 15 years?
That's kind of piss-poor planning. It really is.
Sorry to say it. So, 30 seconds remaining. You got it.
I work 60, 70 hours a week, not because I like
to, but because I try to provide for my family so that we can have
the house we live in, the vehicles that we drive, and take vacations,
put food on our table. When these property taxes go up, and they're
going to go up on residents and commercial— commercial is going raise their
cost of living, their prices at the grocery stores,
at the convenience stores, everywhere. And it's going to affect everybody in
this room, not just 220%. Your time
is up. Thank you. Hi, my name is
Elba Maria Perez.
And pretty much everything that I was going to say has been said,
so I don't want to repeat it. The only thing that I have not heard
is that I don't hope,
but I pray that you guys really listen
to what is being said. Each one
of you, really listen, because people are suffering and
you're choking us by these big increases
in taxes.
I really pray that you will listen to what has been said this evening.
That's all.
Walter Peterson.
Hi, good evening. I'm Walter Peterson. I've lived here for about 3 years,
uh, and we just were able to buy a home here in Eagle Mountain,
um, which we're really excited about. I'm a little less excited with the 220%
increase, um, and a lot of my thoughts
have been said. Um, a more moderate view
of this or increase would be appreciated here.
I'm also extraordinarily wary about the school district
coming in next year as a teacher That is something that worries me with
that, where I probably won't have a pay increase for those few years where they're
trying to get going. And so having
maybe a 100%, 130%, I don't know,
a smaller number increase would be greatly appreciated if you
do have time to make that change. I think
that you've heard that from the other people that have spoken this evening,
but We appreciate what you do, and we hope that you listen
tonight. Thank you.
Jacob Moore.
Thank you to the City Council and Mayor Gray. My name is Jacob Moore.
Not intending to make a comment tonight, and I initially strongly opposed this increase.
However, I recently received more clear information to the city's purpose
and why the drastic 221% increase. The state
is planning on passing a law this next legislative session limiting any city
to a 5% increase, so Eagle Mountain City has to do it now
or will be restricted by state policies because Utah's
revenue Not rate-driven, the massive growth has not
increased the city's tax revenue because the rate is lowered to account for the growth,
which keeps the revenue roughly the same. That's something
that I've frequently heard: that we've had so much growth, we should have more money.
But that's apparently not the way it works here in Utah.
It's important to understand that the 221% increase applies only
to the city's portion of your property tax bill, not your. Total property taxes.
For the average homeowner, that translates to roughly a 12% increase
in the overall property tax, not 221%.
The city wants the property tax increase so our full sheriff's contract is paid for
by the property taxes— been said multiple times tonight— not having to
pull those millions from the city's general fund. I've been told that the funds
freed up— the funds freed up in the general fund would be used for infrastructure
and other public safety improvements. If that's true,
then the messaging from the city has not been as misleading
or dishonest as a lot of people are saying. I believe it would
go a long way if the city council and mayor would explain as much as
possible exactly what the freed-up general fund money would be used for,
as others have requested. I do believe
it's unfortunate that the city's hand is being forced by the state legislature, which wants
the step into city policies and tell cities what they are and are not allowed
to do with their tax rates. I'm not opposed
anymore, but I believe a smaller increase, as many others have said, is a better
solution than the proposed increase.
And I did want to add that
I encourage Eagle Mountain citizens to ask the state legislature
to change the property tax to a rate-driven system. So as the population
increases, our revenue does as well. Instead of the current system,
it is forcing the city council's hand to increase our taxes to
increase the revenue. And then I do also believe
that it's— there's been
unintentional confusion. 30 seconds remaining. And it's not the
same as dishonesty as many are claiming tonight. I feel
like a lot of emotions are clouding judgment. I wanna thank you for all you
do. I can't imagine being in your shoes, and I'm glad I'm not.
Have a great night.
We do have a form filled out by Garrett Houghter, who does not
want to make a verbal comment, but did note down, I want to echo what
Charlotte Duco said. And then our next one is Jason Rasmussen.
Good afternoon. Jason Rasmussen. I've been a resident here for
3 years. First of all, I want to thank all of you for the
efforts that you make, and I want to thank our
public first responders for all the things
that they do to, to keep our city safe.
I think A lot of the frustration that we're
hearing is essentially what you did is you held up a
marble that said public safety and you put it under a cup
and then you had 3 other cups. You flipped them around,
you pulled up the cups, and what you revealed was a card that
said 210% tax increase.
And so we're a little bit confused how this public safety marble
is replaced with a, a 210% or 220%
tax increase. Um, and I know that a lot of people
have already expressed, um, that we just need more transparency about,
like, how the monies would be spent. We need more
transparency about how money could be reclaimed. We need
more transparency about how money could be saved.
How you can retrench in ways. So it's essentially
just what can you do to kind of let us know how the money is
going to be spent? Are there other sources of revenue?
And how can you retrench in places that you can retrench?
And I would add just one additional item.
I know that a lot of the data centers that have been built in Eagle
Mountain have been built with, you know, tax breaks of
up to 77%. $150 million,
and that's a large percentage more than the $6
million revenue that you're trying to get. And it
seems in some ways like you gave a break to artificial intelligence
at the expense of all the human intelligences in
this room and in our community. So thank you.
Thank you.
Joy Rasmussen.
So in 2018, Facebook got
tax breaks on their property taxes that
was pretty hefty, and some of you were involved
in that. It was $150 million. in property tax incentives
that they are not paying for, what, 40 years? So that's money the
city could have been using all this time that you took away from us.
And then 2021, more data centers were given $77
million in property tax incentives, again for Meta.
QTS is currently building more data centers that
are for Meta and Google, and they have also been given tax breaks
on sales tax. So the city has made a choice. Do we tax
data centers to build AI to take our jobs and
take our children's jobs and then tax the residents,
or do we not do that? And you have made those choices. Now, to say
that you're paying the price for previous politicians— most of you have been
here in city politics for many years. You have voted.
Last year's budget, you did not increase property taxes,
but you added public safety officers, and you bragged about it on your
website. I took the screenshot tonight. Somehow you managed to do it before, but now
you're saying you can't anymore. I have done some research, and guess
what? When you add data centers to your city, public infrastructure costs
go up. So somebody in this, in this town, Alex Washburn,
has done a GRAMA request and asked you guys for information
about why you're doing this and where you're spending the money and what capital projects
this is going to go towards, because that's what it's for. And his request was
denied, and you made him— you're going to charge him a huge fee he can't
afford. And then you met with him and somehow got him to think it
was necessary. But here's the thing. We have a lot more houses in Eagle Mountain
than we did before. So even if the amount that you can charge per house
has not increased, the number of houses has increased.
So you still have more revenue with the increase in citizens.
This is absolutely to fund the data centers. There's an electrician in Eagle Mountain that
has messaged me. He works at the data centers. He said that QTS wants to
put 27 data centers in Eagle Mountain. There's already about 7 approved.
And that's— he said if he lived here, he would be upset.
He said he's not going to stay because the energy costs and the water costs
are going to skyrocket. He doesn't understand why the residents are not upset. The city
has been trying to put nuclear reactors in the city for the data centers.
All of you in this room need to know this and wake up. We need
to fight this like Box Elder County. Thank you. because we are already paying the
price. These data centers are getting the break and we're getting dorked over. 30 seconds
remaining. People can't afford it. There's a lady I know who messaged
me. She is elderly. Her husband has dementia and Parkinson's.
They are on fixed incomes. And she said, our house is paid for, but we
cannot afford this property tax increase. My husband's gonna have to go into a
care center for $5,000 a month. This is going to bankrupt us. You need
to think about those people and not do this. This is totally inappropriate. There needs
to be more time. and more public disclosure about where this money is really going
and what infrastructure you're putting it towards, what capital projects, and give— listen
to the people. Your time is up. Thank you.
Michael Carey.
Michael Carey. I'm going to read this. Mayor and members of
the City Council, thank you for your service and for the opportunity to speak tonight.
I want to begin by saying that I support public safety. I believe our deputies
and first responders deserve the resources they need to protect our growing community.
As Eagle Mountain continues to grow, it is reasonable to expect that the cost
of providing those services will grow as well. My concern is not whether we
should invest in public safety. My concern is the size of the proposed
increase and whether residents have been given the complete financial picture.
The city's public information states that every dollar of the proposed increase will go toward
funding the sheriff's contract and expanding public safety. At the same
time, the city's public— published materials also discuss other financial
pressures facing Eagle Mountain, including rapid population growth,
inflation, increased road maintenance, parks infrastructure, and other essential
city services. If public safety is the immediate
use of these new tax dollars, I understand that. But if broader budget
pressure— pressures are also contributing to the need for
this increase, I believe residents deserve a transparent discussion about
those challenges as well. An informed public is better able to support difficult
decisions. I would also encourage the City Council to consider a phased approach
instead of implementing the full increase in a single year.
A 3 to 5 year graduated plan would still provide additional
funding for public safety while giving families time to adjust to higher property
taxes during a period when many are already experiencing
rising costs in housing, insurance, groceries,
and utilities. A 3 to 5— sorry,
a phased approach would also allow the city to measure results along the way.
Before each phase, the City Council could publicly report measurable
outcomes such as improvements in emergency response times,
changes in deputy workload and staffing ratios, growth in calls
for service, progress toward clearly defined public safety goals,
Whether growth-related revenues or operational efficiencies have reduced
the need for future tax increases. I would also respectfully
ask the council to explain why 7 additional deputies represent
the appropriate staffing level and what objective analysis supports that
recommendation. Understanding the data behind the proposal will help public
confidence. Finally, I encourage the council to continue exploring
every available option to reduce the burden on taxpayers,
including efficiencies within city operations,
careful prioritization of spending, and identifying growth-related
revenue sources before asking residents to absorb significant
increases in property taxes. Please conclude. I believe Eagle Mountain residents are willing to invest
in their community when they understand the need and have confidence in the plan.
Transparent, measurable, and great— a gradual approach can strengthen
that trust while still meeting city's responsibilities, keep our community safe.
Thank you for your time and service and for your consideration.
Camille Gardner.
I don't see Camille. We'll add her paper to the record.
Please remember you represent those who elected you. We don't need additional police,
nor all the other projects you think we do. We want economy at
the city. Like Stuart Adams, we will vote you out if
you vote for this increase. Additionally, we don't need Ranches Parkway widened. We need
a right-hand turn lane.
KB Bergenson.
Good evening. K.B. Bergeson. I've lived here about 3 years.
Before that, I lived in California and Washington, and I moved here to get away
from those places, so I was glad to be here. But I
am a 7-year Army veteran, and I also retired
from law enforcement. I worked for a sheriff's office.
So I have deep respect and am grateful for the services they
do provide us. Thank you. And I'm grateful, you know,
for their service and what they, you know, do for us.
I'm 75 years old, and I live with my daughter
and her family. I came here to join with them
so we could be on a budget and survive the economy.
I'm on a fixed budget. I'm retired. With that
in mind, I don't think that we need a 220% increase
in property tax. to support
law enforcement and what they're doing. I emailed
all of you, you know, asking you about this,
and I did receive one response from Craig, and I appreciate that.
I thought it was very insightful. I quote, he said,
also, I don't think we need— that we'll end up
needing a 220% increase. In the past few weeks, we've been diving into
the numbers, and I think the city can get by with a small smaller number
than 220%. I'm not sure what number. It will still be a
large increase, but not 220%. A few comments I'll give you since
I've been on the council for 3.5 years. We anticipate—
next year we anticipate revenue— that data
center revenues will take a jump. We need an increase to help with additional needs.
If next year doesn't bring enough data center revenue, I'm sure 3 and 4 years
we'll see that money coming in. Further, we should have
Smith development online by then as well, and I think there's a realistic possibility to
revisit that increase. I think if that's the case,
if that's in mind, we should take a measured approach to any increase right
now. There's other things that can be done for law enforcement, too. I know
that there's other places I've been, they've had a citizens patrol where
they have seniors volunteer to take a workload off of deputies.
That can be done, and maybe that can be looked into. There's a lot of
other things that be done and looked into to help with law enforcement without,
you know, budgeting huge amounts of money. I'm on a fixed
balanced budget, and I think that the city should also be on a fixed balanced
budget. You need to take the funds that you make and use
them wisely and determine what takes priority and spend that money— 30 seconds remaining.
—according to those priorities, and other things should not be done until the money
comes in and it can be spent accordingly. Thank you very much.
Steve Campbell.
Mayor Gray, councilmen, Councilman Wright,
I'm a 20-year resident. I'm going to make this really simple.
I think we've been here long enough and everyone has said a lot, but I
have a question. The other day I just happened to hear that
the federal government Office of Management and Budget
provides grants to cities. A grant is free money. I mean,
it's not free, it's our tax dollars to the federal government.
They will provide grants to cities to upgrade
public safety, police departments, this type
of thing. I wasn't aware of this. I don't know if you folks are
aware or not. If you're not, it bears
looking into. Yes. If you have, great.
I don't know the process for applying for
a grant. I do know they're available. My daughter gets
them all the time from the federal government for disadvantaged children in the
school systems. So just point of interest.
Anyway, good to see you, Brett. Good to see you all. Thank you very much.
Shedrick D. Shermond.
Feel free to correct me if I'm not close. Okay. Yeah,
for the record, Cedric DeChermond. Um, I was going to write this with the help
of AI, but the Wi-Fi wouldn't connect, and I thought maybe it's a little too
ironic to not just speak from the heart.
So my wife and I moved to Eagle Mountain a little over 3 years ago
due to the prospect of affordable living, safety,
well-planned growth strategy, and to raise our own family.
I've worked and lived all across this country. This is the first home I've ever
bought, and I'm proud of it. As a young family, our budget is tight,
and our options are weighed when we spend our hard-earned money.
We want to start a family and often deliberate how.
I won't explain what it is you're doing in economic principles.
Plenty of us have already done that already, and frankly, should already know.
Taxes and costs often go up and rarely go down.
I worry that you already know that too. The proposed tax
increase, or upon its original inception, does not even begin to address
concerns regarding the following: future impacts due to the new school
district— and my wife is a teacher— um, current shortfalls
in infrastructure and future growth of infrastructure needs. The irony
in the truth and transparency is that as taxpayers, we are
seeing a limited view you into the current stewardship of the use of our current
tax revenue. If you are a poor steward now, you will be a worse steward
with more. But as a general populace,
we cannot contend with what we do not know and what you are failing to
accurately disclose. We as citizens can't keep up with all of
the wavering of priorities and promises being potentially broken. We can nonetheless see
that you are ostensibly lying. Are all of the
developers, outside contractors, and multibillion-dollar industries that operate
and profit off of our city paying their fair share? We all know the answer.
You want to hold our feet to the fire but won't stand against them.
Can you account for the impact of this proposed tax increase in terms of
hungry mouths, missed payments, and ultimately families no longer
being able to call Eagle Mountain their home? I don't think you can.
You can't share the budget you have, and you can't show the forecast for the
projects you want. A lot of people blame young kids for the hoodrat behavior
and damage we see growing around here. I blame parenting.
Can we account for the lack of parental guidance as a result of them
having to work harder to pay for this fund? Are we operating
in a banana republic? I and others helped elect you in those chairs
on the principles of family values, economic frugality, and fiscal conservatism.
Is this tyranny? We have enough of that going on in our country and in
our world. This shitty council should reject those ends. I would
request that you consider a motion to defer this vote until you can better communicate
your past decisions, future, future intents, and your clearly stated budget
objectives to the community that deserves to hear a transparent truth of the situation.
Thank you.
Isaac Gardner.
He did provide a written comment in opposition to the tax increase.
We will add it to the For the record, Daniel Lamb— Lob.
Feel
free to correct me if I'm incorrect on your name. For some reason
it's always Lamb. It's Lob.
Anyway, thank you for having this opportunity for
us to speak. I'm here not because I want to be, like a
lot of other people. We have a lot of other things we want to be
doing. But we're so against this increase, that's why we're here.
We can't, we don't feel that we can afford this.
Transparency has been discussed. Like, I just agree with all the other comments that
have been made. Like, that's probably the best way to sum it up.
Yeah, right now we're not buying it. We're just, we don't buy what
you guys are proposing. We don't agree to it. That's why I'm here is to,
you know, make my voice heard. Don't agree to it.
There's—it's not the best thing,
and I hate to say this. Like I'm not trying to be offensive, but the
citizens, like for myself, I will try to make sure you're not
reelected again. I will. If this passes, just know it
may be your last term. So anyway, we appreciate everything else you're
doing that's that's positive, and not trying to be negative here, but we
really don't want this increase. And if it goes through and
you pass it, it's a death knell. Pretty sure about that.
Shawna Clark.
Is that right? Shawna?
Okay.
I wasn't going to get up today because I'm not very eloquent and there's
been a lot of people that have talked very well.
But the more I sat there, the more I just wanted to make sure that
I'm just not a person sitting in the audience observing, that you know how
I feel. In September of 1998, my family moved out here.
So next month will be 28 years that I've been out here. We moved
out here because we couldn't afford to live anywhere else. I raised
my kids out here. I became single out here through divorce.
And I've been able to stay here. Thank you. My youngest daughter and
her 4 kids, age range in age from 3
to 9, live with me as well. She stays
home to take care of the kids, and I make $16 an hour.
I've heard it said about the impact fees.
The homes being built, more money that
way. I just feel like with the
tax breaks that other big businesses get and then
being scammed out of the money, I feel like me as a $16
an hour person am being asked to pay that. It is not
my fault. Not that it's your fault, not all
of it. But I feel like this is a huge
ask of you guys. Not ask, you're not asking us, you're just gonna do it.
I've had to refinance my house a few times to get my ex-husband
off, to get money out because I couldn't afford
things. And the last time was to lower
my interest rate. So even though I've been out here for almost 28 years,
I still owe 25 years on my house. It's not like I
can save many other places. So I really wish
you would think about how this affects the small people.
Dax Steadily.
I do not see him present. Also in opposition to the tax increase.
We will add his comment to the record. Colton Hart.
I do not see him in opposition to the tax increase.
We'll add his comment to the record. Sadie Hart,
also opposition to the tax increase.
We'll get that one added as well.
Melissa Gordette.
She states, please don't raise our taxes. I do not see her in person.
We'll add her comment to the record. Kristen Meyer.
Good evening, Mayor and City Council members. My name is Kristen Meyer and
I'm a resident of Eagle Mountain. I'm here tonight to urge you to vote no
on the proposed tax increase. Let me state why.
Roughly $1.5 million is allocated to the Utah County Sheriff's contract.
I don't have an issue with that. My issue is
with the remaining amount that has been— it hasn't been
allocated clearly enough. We wanna know
exactly how it will be spent. Thank you.
These are public funds and we need transparency, not vague line items.
Second, how did we get here? The podcast indicated
that a failed bill from the previous legislative session may have capped— it
might have capped future tax increases. Fair enough.
But your response, along with other cities, seems to be that we should
raise taxes now before the state can cap us in the future.
And the bill failed. And what is the response? As a
city, you knew we were growing. You approved the development.
You approved the growth. And instead of having the common sense to plan
for the roads and the infrastructure and all the needs that we require,
you failed to act.
Third, we are in an affordability crisis. It's a crisis
fueled in part by greedy corporations. And the politicians who
too often put the powerful interests ahead of the hardworking Americans.
I propose you lower the tax to cover only the sheriff's contract.
And before these words fall on deaf ears,
think about the people you represent. Think about the senior living
on a fixed income. Think about the mother wondering how she's going to
make it to the next paycheck. Think about the people who have experienced the
embarrassment of having their credit card declined.
Although we do not have the power to decide how you vote,
we do have the power to decide who votes in these seats tomorrow.
And I ask that you earn our trust. Vote no on this proposal
as it stands, and we ask for greater transparency.
Thank you.
Cheryl Carr.
Good evening. My name is Cheryl Carr.
We bought our land in 1998.
We built our home in 2004.
Been here for 22 years. I'm 71
years old. Thank you. My husband is 76.
Our property has more than doubled
since we've been here. Our income has
not. That value is not realized
unless we sell our home. I want to
read President Donald Trump
has— he may be federal, but this is his view.
He has proposed eliminating local property taxes for homeowners
aged 65 and older who have fully paid off
their mortgages. He characterized property taxes as a
form of perpetual rent that prevents seniors on
fixed incomes from From truly owning their own homes.
Relief for fixed incomes— supporters state the plan protects
older Americans from raising housing insurance and
valuation costs. Aging in place— advocates
argue it helps retirees keep their lifelong homes
instead of being forced to move. I will tell you,
if this passes, we will have to sell and we
will have to move.
I know there needs to be more money.
And the people who are coming to Eagle Mountain create
more traffic on the roads. We've all seen that.
So what is the answer? What would you like to see happen?
It's, it's a tough one, but I think that the impact fees
need to be raised. I don't know what they are, but I do know that
this problem is a result of
more people moving here, and they
need to pay for that impact.
And so that would be my request.
That you look at those impact fees and see where things
can be shifted. 30 seconds remaining.
I do thank you for your service and for your time. Thank you.
Roger Laird.
Sorry, I'm not exactly Just as nice as everybody, but my
day started at 2:30 this morning, and I didn't
get off until 4:30 today, and I rushed down
to be here for this.
220% is rather asinine.
I probably more than anybody in here support police
officers and EMS because I spent the entirety of my young adulthood
in EMS. I've been shot at. I've been stabbed.
I've been shoulder to shoulder with police fighting.
And it's not fun. Well, it was, but— But
probably none of you guys have been shot at or stabbed or been in
those situations or watched people die or drug a
wounded police officer that was shot because some gangbanger wanted
some clout while we were on the side of a road at a call.
I work very hard for my money. We moved here because
it was affordable, it was a nice community, and it's a little bit a ways
from it all. You can't
tell me, you can't convince me 220% is
reasonable. Some of you are real estate agents. That is
a negative at asset that you're trying to sell people.
And if you're the kind of real estate agent that sells negative assets
to people, I would probably say you're not exactly an ethical
real estate agent. I did real estate, one of the many things I've
done, besides EMS paramedic, crane operator,
real estate, and mortgage loan officer.
So, The fact that you guys
can't articulate where all that's going other than you're selling it under
the guise of helping the police officers, which is a good thing. I don't
think anybody's opposed to giving them help and the EMS any
help. But those
data centers, which I've worked on, I've been on a crane in there for 16
hours one day. The fact,
and it's you,
Oh, the tax breaks you give them could be paying for all of
this. And, and the, the bullcrap part is you guys
know it, but you give them all these tax breaks.
And then all these builders that want to come in, and we're getting more revenue
from taxes on that. Again, you know it. I'm not saying
you guys— that things weren't mismanaged in the past, but you can fix
it by simply cutting costs and stop giving all these tax
breaks. There's 7 more buildings going in there. I know that because
I work there. Please do better.
Budget like we all do.
Thank you.
Zeke, Zeke Magdalio.
Hi, my name is Zeke Magdaleno. I've been here about 7 years.
I'm kind of neutral, gentleman right here, uh,
between the data centers and a resident because I build them and
I know what they cost. I know what they bring in, and I have to
be careful what I say so I have a job tomorrow.
So, but I, I'm finding
myself not understanding Because I feel it's a duty to—
even though I could lose my job if I'm not careful,
I have to say something for all these people here,
including myself, that might not be able to afford a
home. I was able to, as a single dad,
afford a house on a single income,
raise my children, and I'll be perfectly honest, I hated it
in the middle of the desert. I couldn't stand it. But we've come
a long way in 6 years. So I want
to bring some transparency for the people behind me on
the data centers. And by
the time QTS is done— I can say QTS, we all know it's signs out
there— they're predicted that Eagle Mountain will be the biggest
data center campuses for them in the world.
Not United States, the world.
Let that sink in. So if
we're allowing these data centers to be built and we get— we are getting them
tax breaks, which I understand, we want them to come here
and build these data centers, but isn't that supposed to help these
people, us, out in the long run? That's what I thought.
That's what they're supposed to do. And I know how many they're planning on building.
Honestly, we shouldn't have to pay taxes for our lifetime.
These guys have so much money. I know what they bring in when they rent
these data centers, and it's insane.
It's insane how much money that, that these,
these people have that are building these data centers. So I'm
confused on why 220%
Why are we paying anything? I, I maybe I got here late,
so I'm sorry if this was talked about earlier.
But being that I'm building them and I'm kind of neutral,
I just don't see— and I'm, I, you know, obviously I'm a community
member paying my mortgage. That's insane. I think that comes
out to like $300 more, I think, a month, something like that.
That's crazy. But anyways, just to stick up for the data centers a
little bit, The ones we're building are closed systems. They don't use water
like the other ones, just letting you know. They do in the beginning, but they're
closed. They're not evaporative. That's Facebook.
I worked on that one too. That's all I gotta say.
Megan Streeter.
Does it start when I speak? Hi,
I'm a delegate and precinct chair in Eagle
Mountain and have interacted with several of my city council members.
Nice to see you, Brett. Nice to see you, Melissa. I know you two and
find you to be reasonable, logical humans. And with that said, I do feel like
we are missing a mark here. I do feel that way,
especially with the sheriffs. I do not dislike the sheriffs,
appreciate you, but I do think in the current state we're in, I mean,
I think it's a good idea to invest with them in the current state we're
in, but I do feel that we need our own department.
And with that said,
renting is worse than owning, and I do feel like we are making
a bad decision by renting the sheriffs. I don't think it's an
investment for our city. Aside from that, I do believe we are missing the opportunity
to negotiate with data centers, and he pretty much set me up for success when
he was speaking. I have a unique perspective as I have rented
land from many of the farmers out there by the data centers. I have
watched as these farmers have been cornered. I've watched as they have been
bullied. I've watched even their own cows
be poisoned. And we're not— I mean, there's so many stories you
guys don't know about, and you haven't been out there talking to the farmers.
And if you've ignored them, then you would know what's been going on.
One of those guys out there, he leased his land for $100,000 a
month. And then when he's done leasing, he will be bought out.
And then just one QTS manager gets
$500,000 for 10 months. We need to stop acting like we need the data
centers and start acting like they need us, as they do. We have the land
and the water to provide space for them. Data centers are being banned all over
the nation and in the world, and we know this. It's a hot topic right
now. They need us, period. And they have the money to give us
the full $7 million you need for the 220 increase. I guarantee that
you can negotiate that. Thank you. I have faith in you. I absolutely believe that
you guys could do this because they need us. Eagle Mountain's special. We're unique.
And aside from that, I love this city, and I hope we can
manage these situations in a way that allows us to move forward in
a small-town ideal since a lot of these people moved here for that,
and I did as well. And I absolutely hate your job. I'm sure it's horrible,
but I really think that we're missing the mark, and I really hope we can
do better. Thank you. do something better. I really do.
Tony Castillo.
Tony Castillo. You know, everybody knows
who we are. We own a roofing company. COVID hit us hard.
I saw prices go up every month, my material cost
every month, 10% here, 10% there.
I'd go to my wife, we gotta raise our prices.
And this is after my suppliers were chewing me out because they
were hearing from competitors how I was undercutting them.
And I said, is it affecting your bottom line? I'm still buying
from you guys. The only difference is I'm not getting rich like those
This year, I'm not talking COVID, we had about a 60% price increase.
60% just in one year.
And I got smart, didn't change suppliers,
just negotiated.
This year we had about a 30% price increase because of the war.
I watched my— I'm going to use this to be upfront, guys. My per bundle
price to operate my company for
one brand is $150 a bundle.
That was after the price increase that I got. And I went
back and I said, I can't operate like this.
And, you know, a lot of you guys are my customers.
I had Charlotte ask me, her daughter asked me, how the heck are you $5,000
less than these other companies, but you're doing more?
I want your business. I know my numbers.
I'll go back to my suppliers and renegotiate.
You guys get to renegotiate. Yeah. I support the tax increase.
220%— I mean, I'll be honest with you, it's very shocking.
Can you imagine if I raised my prices 220%?
I mean, Craig, you had a customer beat me up over
the quote I gave him, even a repair. I had to walk
away from it. Had I done it, it would have opened me into a multimillion-dollar
community. Thank you. But my values are a lot worth more than that.
Elections are coming up again.
At the end of the day, guys, do what's right. 30 seconds remaining. A lot
of us can't afford to eat. And I was like,
I'm wondering, you know, can I afford to buy a cow this year
if the rate goes up? 'Cause that's the first thing I'm gonna be cutting.
So thanks, guys. Appreciate y'all.
I have Melanie Castillo who chooses not to make a verbal comment. And while she
states, while I support an increase and see its need, she's interested
to hear from each member of the council the top 3 capital projects. And she's
seen the list and wants to know what's important to the
council members on that one. And then we do have,
we did have a public comment from Matthew Joseph who has
that he would like to discuss the budget. And we just wanna remind you that
this is for the proposed tax rate only, that the budget public hearing will be
on August 18th. So if Matthew Joseph wanted to clarify
that, and I don't see him here, so we will add it to
the record. Joanna Brown.
Hi, Joanna Brown. I'm sorry that I'm dressed this way. I would
never approach in any other circumstance, but I heard a comment that
was made and I had to stop in before I go to my volleyball game.
The comment that was made was made
that somebody said that they support the tax increase, but maybe to
less than 220%. And then the comment was made, maybe it's something that
most probably— most people probably still won't be happy with.
Um, and that got me off of watching it on my phone
and here in front of you, because that's not the way government works.
Government's for the people. So the majority of the people voted
you guys into where you are. The majority of the people are represented by
you, so the majority of the people should be happy with the decisions that are
made. So I guess I just wanted to reiterate that that's—
a democracy is a government for the people,
by the people, and we are in a democratic republic
where we vote for representatives who represent the majority.
So that comment of maybe the majority will be upset, but that's fine,
do what you want to do— no, remember that the majority of the people
are why we have this government and why you're all sitting where you are,
because the majority of us voted for you. Um,
and I guess my other really quick comment before I head out the door was
just thanking Ms. Rasmussen for clarifying that again
it's been put out, which I felt like it was a little bit confusing,
that under that truth in taxation, that yes,
the amount per household stays the same, but because there's
more households There is more money. So,
um, I hope that most people don't come from a house where
dinner was mom coming home with a can of
beans and saying that's all she could afford, and that that can of beans now
cost her $37 instead of $2 because now she was getting
an overdraft fee for it. But I hope
that the city isn't going in a direction because we need whatever
these capital projects are, to put its citizens in that kind of a position.
'Cause I'm grateful I'm not in that position anymore, but I have been, and it
sounds like a lot of our citizens also know what that
feels like. So I'll just ask you to remember that you
represent the majority. Remember, like, try to
make the majority happy, I guess. Thank you for your time.
Thank you.
These public comments are from participants who showed up today,
but does not— they do not wanna make a verbal comment. So I'll just read
the names. They're all in opposition to the tax increase, to be clear.
Trenton Webb, Derek Rappel-Eye,
M. Patrick Mayo,
Brianna Nelson, Alex Nelson,
Jessica Diemers, David Gordette,
and Vienna Portela. Portela.
Thank you.
These are the public comments that came in through via email,
and I am unsure if they are in attendance, so I'll call your name,
and if you're here, come on up. Brittany Mitchell.
She's in opposition to the tax increase, so we'll
get that in the record. Lily Anna Elliott,
also in opposition. Cammie Watterson,
also not here. She states, I'm all for
keeping the city running safe, but why is it 220%?
So she doesn't say for or against. Jill Jones.
I do not see her here. She wishes
to pause the increase of the property taxes.
Susanna Norris.
She's writing to voice the strong opposition to the 220%
increase. Carly King.
Also not here. Opposition to the increase as well.
Brenda Martinez. Hold on. Oh, we do have Carly
King online. Let me double-check that.
Thank you, Carson. Okay, we do have Carly King online, so we
will come back to her. Brenda Martinez.
I do see a Brenda online, so that could be her.
Um, and she— her statement
is, uh, the point is lack of transparency Transparency, so we will get that added
in. Zachary Vance—he
doesn't say for or against either. And then Martin
Indreboi—I
do not see that, and he does not also say for or against.
Okay, so now we're going to move to the virtual comment.
Period. And as a reminder, I will unmute
your mic if you are online, and it will tell you to unmute
it on your side. I will start the timer once you start speaking,
and then once you are finished, you're welcome to stay online to watch the meeting,
but not required to, as you'll only be able to speak once. Am I missing
anything else? Okay, we're just gonna go ahead and start at the beginning.
I see AJ online. I do not see last names on some of them,
so please state your first and last name when you jump on as well.
Okay, we're going to move over to that.
AJ, you should be able to unmute your mic.
Hi, everyone.
He's— looks like he's still muted, so we might
have to come back to him. Should I
unmute? No?
Okay, we're gonna go past AJ and we're gonna go over to Alex Washburn.
See if I can get this one to work. Here we go.
Good evening, Mayor, council members,
and fellow residents. My name is Alex Washburn. Over the
past week, I've spent dozens of hours reading the city's budgets,
attending meetings, filing grandma requests, and trying to understand
why Eagle Mountain is proposing what amounts to a 220% property
tax increase. Yesterday, I had the opportunity to spend
about an hour meeting with Mayor Jared Gray, the city manager,
Council Member Clark, and members of the finance team. I sincerely
appreciate each of them taking the time to answer my questions because
that meeting genuinely changed my understanding of several things.
I now have a much better understanding of how Utah's truth-in-tax law has
affected Eagle Mountain over the last 15 years. As property taxes—
values increased, the certified property tax rate decreased,
while the cost of providing services, especially especially law enforcement,
continued to rise. I now understand why the city has gradually
had to use more and more of the general fund to cover the increasing
cost of the sheriff's contract, leaving less capacity
for roads, infrastructure, parks, and other priorities.
I believe that's a real problem, and I believe it needs to be addressed.
However, I still have 2 significant concerns. The first is the
policy objective itself. During yesterday's meeting, it was explained
that this recommendation was built around fully funding the sheriff's
contract through property taxes. But when I reviewed the 2010 budget,
the last time there's a tax increase, I found that property tax revenue was
approximately $974,000 while police expenditures
were approximately $2 million. So unless I'm misunderstanding those
numbers, property taxes did not fully fund law enforcement even then.
That tells me that fully funding the sheriff's contract through property taxes
isn't simply restoring the way things have always in, it's a policy decision.
And I think taxpayers deserve to understand why that policy was chosen.
Why is it better to have property taxes fully fund the sheriff's contract
instead of continuing to fund it through a combination of property taxes and
other general fund revenues as the city has historically done? My second
concern is how the amount of this increase was determined. During yesterday's meeting,
I asked what I thought was a simple question. If this proposed
tax increase were reduced didn't pass at all, what projects or
priorities would actually be delayed or eliminated. The answer was
that those decisions haven't been made yet. I appreciate the city
genuinely wants public input before making those decisions,
but I respectfully believe that the analysis should have come first. 30 seconds remaining.
I wish the city had come to the public with several funding scenarios.
If we approve the full increase, if we reduce it by 10%, or reduce by
20%. What projects would have to wait?
That would allow taxpayers to have an informed discussion about priorities
instead of simply reacting. Based on everything,
I support raising it to $1.5 million to fund the 2027
sheriff's contract, but I oppose the increase beyond that unless the
city can clearly explain exactly what the remaining dollars will fund
and what projects or priorities— You can't talk—
The next one we have in line is Amy Larcher. I'm going
to go ahead and allow you to talk and unmute your mic.
It looks like she left. Ashley Garside?
Lacey, I see Ashley's on there twice. Is there a chance that the other
mic that she could be using— maybe unmute both of them? Yeah, let me try
to— You unmuted me on accident.
Do I need to click
it again? We will move on to Ben Crabtree.
One moment. Okay, thank you.
All right, Ben. Thanks. Sorry,
I'm just driving back. I really appreciate, uh, each member of the
City Council and, uh, Mayor for hearing our comments. And I think
most of, most of what I would have said is already— has already been stated,
um, in, in regards to those who are on fixed incomes who
Uh, don't have room in the budget for this level of
increase. Uh, it's just, it's way too much.
Um, and I also appreciate— I don't remember her name,
but the, uh, she mentioned
that there have been communications that have been sent out from the city,
uh, about some of these, uh, some, some of the projects
that need to be done or are going to be, um,
done. I would love to see those as well. I think a lot of us
are feeling that same, feeling that same way.
I would also follow up with, follow up on some of the other comments
that were made about the data centers. I really, I can't
imagine how companies like Meta and
Google can come out here and I know they're
gonna, they're gonna, they can, they have enough money to fund
wherever they want to build. And so why would we I don't
know the nature of the negotiations, but I also run my own business.
And so I also have 6 kids. I'm trying to support 6 kids. And so
hearing this, hearing this increase is just, is just wild. And why
are we passing it on to the taxpayers when we could get
some of these companies who are building infrastructure that's going to increase our cost
of electricity and increase the cost of water to,
to foot some of these bills? It just seems like that would be a better
approach. And again, just think
of, think of the number of people in our community. I would— I hope to
be more involved in future city council meetings and look up some of
the data behind our community and looking at how many people are
really struggling. And from a financial standpoint,
and what people are doing to try and already make ends meet,
what can we do? Thank you. in other ways besides raising taxes like
this, especially at such a high rate, to help lower
their burdens. That's what I have to say. Thank you.
Okay, we're going to try Amy
Larcher again. Just give us one moment.
Looks like she left again. Let's go down to Brenda.
I don't know your last name, Brenda.
Okay,
we'll move on to Brett.
Hi.
Okay, we'll move on to Bruce.
Bruce, can you hear us? I think
Cam Pugh.
Can you hear me okay? Yep, go ahead.
Awesome. Yeah, I'm just gonna say simply I agree with everybody.
Um, I think you represent the
people who voted you in. I think that the majority has
a consensus that transparency, um,
hasn't been met for an ask this big.
I think a lot of families open
their wallet and they don't see much.
And I think that you as a council need
to look in your wallets and simply ask yourself,
who do you represent?
You know, I came from a big family,
and I saw
my parents struggle to put food on the table.
And,
you know, it hurts, I think, every person who
grew up seeing their parents Struggle
to put just a meal on the table to feed their kids.
And, um, for a city as big as Eagle Mountain,
I'll be honest with you,
it's not just not right, it's deceptive,
and it's kind of evil to think that you
as a council are going to ask each citizen to open their pockets,
their wallets that might be empty and say,
you know what, we haven't been transparent with you,
but we're going to ask a huge, huge favor.
Give me money that you don't have.
That's all I have to say.
Thanks, Cam. We're going to move on to Carly King.
All right,
I think I'm unmuted. Um, yep, we can hear you. My name,
my name is Carly King. I have lived in Eagle Mountain for
about 11 years, and initially I wasn't going to share very much about myself.
I don't like speaking, but hearing that the
Council members have pretty
much already made up their minds, saying that their hands
were being forced. I feel like it's important for you guys
to all understand the weight that you are
putting on the shoulders of your citizens. Um, so just a little bit about
my family. I'm the mom of a 2-year-old.
My husband and I both work full-time. I have to manage working
full-time while also being home with my daughter. Thank you.
And trying to be a present parent to her while keeping my job.
This is my reality because I can't— we can't afford to lose
one of our incomes. We already struggle as it is.
We have medical debt, bills, groceries, gas, diapers,
as does everyone else. And sometimes we have to choose
between any one of those items. Which one are we going to pay this
month? Thank you. Um, so I
am against this 220% tax increase. This is going to
devastate many families in Eagle Mountains.
Single-family incomes will become nonexistent,
and this is going to force many mothers that are able
to currently stay home with their kids back into the workforce.
Moms deserve better. And so do those kids.
Um, voting for this is a vote— um,
sorry, the city is going to, um, make a decision without
being transparent, and the suggestion
of a 220% increase is pretty
egregious. We haven't been presented with
data. We've just been told it's going to public safety. Thank you. And like many
other people have echoed, nobody's against public safety,
but you aren't being truthful.
Everyone's already living paycheck to
paycheck. So what you're asking is for people to take time away from
their families, to work more hours, and to cut back on
necessities, um, just to be able to afford this
tax increase. You should all be ashamed. Thank you.
Whoever votes for this, you are
the ones that have to go home and live with yourself. 30 seconds remaining.
You're stealing from the pockets of the citizens of the city.
Eagle Mountain needs to manage our tax dollars better.
You need to hold the city employees to a higher standard, hold them accountable for
fraud, waste, and abuse. In addition, stop giving
data centers astronomical tax breaks.
Thank you.
Thank you. Uh, next one we have is Chris. I don't
have a last name on this. We will ask to unmute.
Okay, moving on. Um, the next one we have is just Citizen. I'm unsure
if you would like to make a public comment.
Okay, the next one we have is Courtney.
All right, uh, the next one we have, the title is Elder
and Sister Squire. Unmute your
mic if you'd like to give a public comment at this time.
Okay, the next one we have is Embritt.
Um,
we have, we have a couple more, so why don't we do this? Um,
if you would like to give a public comment and you're currently on our Zoom
portal, will you please raise your hand?
All right, that'll work.
All right, oops, there we go. We're going to start with Steve Muggleson.
Can you hear me? Yes, there you go. Yep. Okay, uh,
like everyone here, I want my community to be safe. I support our deputies,
and I support giving law enforcement the resources that they need to to protect
the citizens. This isn't about public safety.
This isn't whether or not public safety is important, because it is. But placing
this tax burden solely on the residents is egregious.
Eagle Mountain residents are already carrying heavier
financial burdens than they were just a few years ago. A Forbes survey
finds that 78% of Americans consider themselves living paycheck
to paycheck. Mortgage payments have increased.
Property insurance has gone up. Groceries cost more.
Utilities cost more. Nearly every household expense has
risen. People must make difficult choices every month,
and now the city is asking them to shoulder one of the largest property tax
increases in its history. At the same time, Eagle Mountain
has welcomed some of the largest and wealthiest companies in the world to
build multi-million dollar data centers in our community.
To attract these projects, the city approved redevelopment agreements
that reimburse a substantial portion of the new property
tax revenue those developments generate.
Homeowners should not become the default solution every time the
city needs more revenue, while generous incentive agreements
remain in place for billion-dollar companies. How much tax revenue has
been reimbursed to these major data center develop— This
money is going straight to the pockets of those who don't even know Eagle Mountain
exists and do not support the community that they use.
This isn't about opposing growth or law enforcement.
This is about fairness, accountability, and transparency. Thank you.
Thanks, Steve. We'll move on to Joel Anderson online.
Yeah, thanks for taking your time to listen to
us. A lot of what I was going to say has already been said,
so let me just maybe pitch one possible
alternative to the 220% increase.
Doing a little bit of research, looking back
at 2016,
we were paying about $6.50 $67.53
per capita for public safety. In 2026, it's estimated to
be about $63.16 per capita,
adjusted for— adjusted to 2016
dollars. So we're spending roughly
6.9%, uh, less than,
than what we should be if we were to be on par with 2016.
So, if we were to do something like maybe add
3 new sheriffs rather than 7, that would get
us actually a little bit over that, being on par with 2016.
And then if we were to take that $5.3 million
that is currently being pulled from other
budgets to help help pay for the current
sheriff contract. If we were to cut that in half and
leave half of it to pay for sheriffs
and public safety, and then put the other roughly $2.7 million
back toward the original, I guess, back toward
other projects, that would— That would be a good idea.
leave the new property tax— let's
see, excuse me. Anyway, that would result
in about an 8% property tax increase that would be required to
get us into that range.
Anyway, maybe something like that might be an alternative that it
would reduce the the
tax change from 220% to 8%, it would put
$2.7 million back into other projects, and it would increase
the sheriff's capacity by 3 sheriffs.
And so anyway, just, just a thought, something along those lines
possibly could be a more tempered approach
to what's needed here. 30 seconds remaining.
Let's see, I did. Yeah, also, well, yeah, that's all I
have to say. I think everything else has been said. I don't want to beat
a dead horse. Thank you.
Thanks, Joel. Uh, the next one we have is Joe. I do not have a
last name on here, so please ensure that you give us your last name for
the record. Yes, my name is Joe Richmond.
Um, thank you for the time. Um,
so it's interesting going towards the end of this comment.
Thank you. In the last year and a half, there have been a lot of
common themes that have come up: lack of transparency,
not knowing where the money's going, and we're asking to pay more
money, more in taxes to cover things. And maybe,
you know, the City Council— being in leadership is not easy. I understand
that. I've been in leadership my entire career, and I understand that you see things
and have context that the citizens probably
don't have, and, and that's why you're elected.
But part of your job as being elected is to communicate
well, to be transparent, to simplify
and make it easy for citizens who— how many people have come
up who have sacrificed to be here to, to voice
their comment and their opposition to this, as I am?
And we don't have time in our daily lives to, to research
this and become experts. And so if
this many people are coming to the table and are opposed to this because we
don't understand it and it's not clear where the money's
going, then you have failed at your job at leadership.
It is your job to help us understand it. It's your job
to— we may not like it, but if we can understand
it, I think we have a better chance of supporting something. We have to do
that all the time as adults. as leaders, right? So that is
what I ask and expect from leadership. And I think everybody
that's present in the room, that's online, that's listening,
and those that haven't been able to join to
voice their opinion— I've talked to so many people who can't even join because they're
busy running businesses, they're busy with life, and they can't vote
their— voice their opinion here. So my— I want
to voice my opposition to this. Not because it's
a big increase. Maybe it's needed, but you have not done your
job to let us— to simplify, to help us to understand what's
happening. I mean, and especially with the data centers,
help us to understand how there is such a— how
we're giving such tax breaks to these, these large corporations
with deep pockets, and yet families And
households that don't have deep pockets, we can't just raise funds
for 220% for— to buy a
new car or whatever. 30 seconds remaining. So I'm asking
that, please take a step back,
pause, and do a better job of communicating and
helping us understand what it is you're trying to accomplish. Trust your citizens
to understand what you're seeing. and explain it to
us in a simple way so that we can maybe get behind.
Maybe we don't need the 220%, maybe we need 150% or
whatever it is, but help us understand it. Thank you for your time.
The last one we have online is Zachary Vance.
Hello. I feel like Joe led right into my points.
Basically, as a Democracy as
an experiment in self-governance. A lot of this comes down to adequate representation.
And I don't even know where the citizenry lands on how many support it,
how many reject it. I get the feeling after tonight that if you took this
to some kind of ballot initiative somehow, we would likely be rejecting this.
And honestly, the bottom line is nobody cares what
you think as the city council. As the city council, you were elected to represent
us. So I just want to have more transparency On how you're adequately representing
the will of the people. That's what you were elected to do. You need to
represent the will of the people. And if the people are against you and you
see a better reason, like Joe just said, explain yourself.
With clear communication, we could be on board. We might support
you. But I don't even know if you're listening. I don't know if you've done
anything to listen to your constituents and adequately represent
them. That's the point of this democracy. That's the point of your job.
You need to represent your people. It does not matter what you think.
It is about the people you represent, and that is my only point.
All right, thank you, Zachary. Um, I want to reiterate,
anybody online who would like to participate, will you please raise your hand at
Okay, we're going to go ahead and move over to the email submission. Oh,
we have Joe already spoke, correct?
Joe? Yeah.
Yes, Joe Richmond already spoke.
So we will move over to the email portion. We got a couple emails through,
um, our— to the recorder. We have one from David Salazar.
Thank you, Mayor, council members, for working so hard to ensure the city can
continue providing strong public safety services and and funding the critical projects
for our community needs. My father taught me that true character is revealed when
we are faced with adversity. I appreciate each of you being willing to stand in
the face of criticism and confrontation and still make the decisions you believe are right,
not for yourselves, but for political gain, but for the long-term betterment
of our city. So he says, thank you for your service, courage, and your commitment
to the future of Eagle Mountain City. The other public comment that we got
through email is from Gary Fuchs. He did email it to the
council on August 3rd. It's a lengthy email, so we'll make sure it's part of
the record. But he says he's unable to attend.
He doesn't want to pay higher taxes, but understands the 22% increase gets
people's attention and continues to say, my hope is that the investment is followed
by regular incremental planning so Eagle Mountain never again faces the need for an increase
of this magnitude. And then the last email
we got was from Steve. received profit. It was also sent to the council,
looks like on August 6th, this morning.
Thank you for your dedication to the future of the city. I understand that proposing
a tax increase is a difficult decision. And he
talks about how the proposal will directly affect his family.
He asks that you vote no to the proposed increase and revise the budget
with outcomes-based plan that lessens the financial impact on the residents.
Mayor, that is all of the public comments that I have received at this time.
I will move it to Lacey, I will. I'm going to
forward you one that just came in at 8:03 to the council. Can you send
it to recorder at Eagle Mountain, please? Stephanie will get that printed.
Okay, while he's doing that, can you hear me okay? Yes, we can hear you,
Mayor. I just wanted to— Mayor, Mayor, hold on.
It's the Portella, yeah. It says
on there to read it.
Yeah, remind me of her name, please. Vienna. That's right.
Coretta.
No, that's not appropriate.
All right, we received it. Uh, it was, it was a packet of
opposition to the tax increase, and it's read, no other city in Utah Utah has
ever passed a 22% tax increase. 220% tax
increase. We'll get
that one printed.
Okay. So this is the email that was just received to our office from
Ethan Neal. who is a husband, father of 2, and a resident of Eagle Mountain.
If the city council chooses to approve the proposal, which would increase my property
taxes by approximately 220% and place an even greater
burden on my families already struggling in my community, I will
make it my mission to ensure residents are aware of how each council member voted.
I urge you to consider the financial impact of this proposal that will
have on the families you were elected to represent. So we'll make sure
to get that printed for the packet as well. Thank you.
Now I think we have them all, Mayor.
Okay, I just wanted to give, uh, one last chance. Is there anyone in person
that did not get a chance to speak, would like to, please make it known.
Anybody? I see nobody. Thank you. Hold on,
hold on, Mayor. We have one raised hand. Hold, please.
Okay, please state your name for the record and
fill out a sheet if you would. You can return it to the recorder afterwards.
Of course, will do. So my name is Chris Waldron,
and, uh, I didn't want to talk, but I kept
thinking all night, what would Rich Wood do? And he would make
his voice known. So I want I want to
applaud you for your example of fearless being able to speak and say what
you want. I listened to the Pitch Book podcast,
and I was appalled at a comment that was made about we're
doing this tax increase because the state is
going to could potentially cap the city's ability to
increase it, and to me. The fact
that that's admitted kind of shocked me. It made me think
of Tiffany Walden and the comments she's made about malfeasance.
I just don't think that's ethical to increase
at such a high rate because the
state might stop our ability to do it. It completely exemplifies
why the state would have to have that bill even on
the table. So that was it.
Thanks.
Okay, one more time, is there anyone else in person that would like to make
a comment at this time? There's one in the
back I can see. Same instructions, if you'll get a paper
to Lacey when you're done, state your name for the record. My name is Eric
Nelson. I as well didn't want to speak, but 220%
is above egregious.
It's only the iron horse or the Trojan horse. It's just
the start. What 220% is this year, what's it going to
bring to us in the future? There's claims for a
new city hall, a rec center. I agree that if
this goes through, You guys aren't going to be elected
and you won't be using that city hall.
The financial burdens that are being put on the families for this
kind of increase— they can barely afford groceries, their bills,
just surviving, barely keeping their heads above water— and you want to provide them
with a community center that they can't afford to even use?
It's just so far out there.
I moved to Eagle Mountain a year ago. Moved to Eagle Mountain
a year ago because this is the only place I could afford. And now
these kinds of increases are happening.
It's going to very quickly make this a place that's not affordable to live.
I left Salt Lake County to live somewhere that I could afford.
This is going to turn into Salt Lake County if you approve this.
There will be even more problems. In this community
with a 220% increase. Support our law enforcement
100%, but 220% doesn't
need to support our law enforcement. A much smaller number can support our law enforcement.
That's all I got.
Okay, I'm going to stay, uh, in person. Was there anyone else that feels like
they did not get an opportunity to address the council?
I don't see anyone. Lacey, uh, have we received any
last-minute emails? We got one more. Yep. Okay.
Hello, my name is Elisa Harless, and,
um, I've come to city councils a little bit, and,
um, I'm newer to Eagle Mountain. I work in
a local dental office here, and I know
that when I'm presenting treatment plans to families,
a lot of them struggle to provide proper dental care for their
children, for their families, because they can't afford it.
I know that we came and met with the City of Commerce,
and I know that you guys try and help small
businesses, but your choice of
doing this is going to be detrimental to those small companies that are
trying to thrive. That moved to Eagle Mountain for a purpose because they
can't afford Salt Lake County. They can't afford the east side. They move out here.
They're families that both parents work and they
live on low incomes and they already can't afford their medical bills
and their dental bills. And, you know, they ask to make payments on
things and they're really struggling. And it's real out there. And I don't know if
you guys can even relate to that. I don't know your personal situations.
But what's going on, I feel like, and I feel like a lot of people
feel like this too, that there's been a lot of mismanagement of money.
And I don't know if you guys know history, but it sounds like a lot
of the French Revolutionary, where King Louis was overspending and keeping
it secret and not being transparent
with his people until they realized what was going on, and look what happened to
them. It's getting to the point where you guys are responsible
for our money, and using it wisely. It's not your money to
spend, it's our money, and you need to treat it and
respect it and have integrity and have a voice and know
how to say no and stand up to these big corporate companies.
But to me, and I feel like a lot of people feel like that too,
is there's been really a lot of poor decisions made in
the past government of the city, and we know, we know
it. Thank you. We know it and we recognize it and we've had
enough of it and we're saying no. So think about history.
Think how, you know, government has changed because of poor decisions with spending
money and being bankrupt and not telling the people, and it's gonna come out.
So for me, I feel like that's why you have to increase taxes
so much is because you're— we could be bankrupt. We don't
even know. And you have to keep increasing taxes to
make up for poor excuses and poor decisions that you guys made in the past.
And I know that some of you are new to that. 30 seconds remaining.
But there's people that have been on the board for a long time that were
part of those poor decisions, and it's unfortunate that they still
get voted in. I don't know why, um, but something has to
So, okay, thank you, uh, Lacey. I did see a couple online. I know
there's a Joe and also I just lost the other one. Can we
go to those 2 real quick? Yep. Uh, Tim Blair.
Yes, uh, I,
uh, am calling remotely now, but I just, uh, uh,
couldn't let this pass without getting my 2 cents in.
I've lived in Eagle Mountain now about 4 years.
Last year my taxes went up about $800
a year. That's about $70 a month,
uh, for evaluation and one thing and another.
And, uh, you know, that doesn't sound like a lot, but it is to
me a lot. Uh, and, uh, I've lived all over
the United States pretty much. And, uh,
the reason the poorest places I ever lived in were the ones that had the
highest taxes. And, uh, you know,
uh, out here, this community We've got a lot of things
going for us. And I just— I
don't know that I could afford to, to keep, you know,
getting that kind of tax increase every year.
So, you know, I'm totally set against
this, this 220-something percent increase.
And just wanted to say that I
think it's a losing proposition. Thank you. So for a lot of us.
So that's all I've got. Thank you.
Okay. I think this is a different Joe.
We did hear from one Joe. So would you check and see if this— if
Joe has spoke, maybe state the last name?
Yep. He's the same one that had spoke already. Looks like he recognizes the picture.
Okay.
Was there— before I go on, I just wanted to double-check. I'm running 2 devices
here. Sorry, I'm a little slow. Was there anyone else online
who did not get the opportunity to speak? If they would
raise their hand, please.
Oh, actually, I'm trying to run the 2 devices,
and I believe on Joe's device, his wife wanted to speak. Roxanne, is that correct?
Uh, can we ask if Roxanne wants to speak? Gotcha. Okay,
yeah, we'll get him unmuted. Yeah,
my name is Roxanne Richmond. Go ahead,
Roxanne, we'll get you going. Okay, thank you for— thank
you for, um, listening to me. Um, my family and I have lived in Eagle
Mountain for 7 years, and we really love the community here. I really believe
that the city council members and the mayor are good people.
Jared called me personally the other day to help me understand why the city
needs more revenues, and that makes some sense.
However, I took the time to compare this proposed tax rate of
0.00171 to
other cities in Utah County, and what I found is that that rate is extremely
high, even in comparison to cities like Orem. Thank you.
Linden, Highland, Alpine, and Saratoga Springs.
I wanted to figure out if this proposed
tax rate was sensible in comparison to other cities
which happen to have far more services,
although they're not— some of them aren't going through as much rapid development as Eagle
Mountain. But what I've concluded is that it is an extremely high
rate and that the citizens should not be asked to foot this bill.
I support improved law
enforcement, but I would ask the City Council to go back to the drawing board
and reevaluate what's
needed, prioritize and renegotiate
with the data centers and try to bring in revenues elsewhere because this burden
would be far too much and asking far too much of taxpayers.
Thank you.
Okay, if there was anyone else online, if you'd please raise your hand
if you have not spoke. One final chance there. Also, I wanted to
ask Lacey, have there been— maybe I think Stephanie's
tracking— is there anyone that has emailed in in the last few minutes that
we did not get to? We will double-check.
No, no more emails. Okay, and I don't see any hands raised
on the computer.
Last call for those in person who have not had a chance
to speak. Is there anyone there that feels like they would like to speak?
I don't see anyone standing.
Last call for anyone online, emails,
I want to make sure everybody feels like they've been heard and had a chance.
Are we good, Lacey? Uh, we have Tyler Duclos online
that just raised his hand. Okay. We'll get him unmuted.
Hi everyone, my name is Tyler Duclos. I've lived
in Eagle Mountain for over 7 years, and I lived in Lehigh
where Eagle Mountain was a part of it. Um, my whole family lives
out here. And for a tax increase, a property
tax increase of 220%, I'm opposed to it.
I'm all for supporting our police or our sheriff's department
and public safety, but I am like most that I've heard tonight,
think that we got to go back and find it elsewhere.
Taxes are killing us already. You know, I, I can barely
afford groceries. Thank you. medical supplies. I'm a type 1
diabetic and I'm having to go without, you know.
And talking with family, friends,
neighbors, you know, majority of my
circle are all for, uh, supporting our
Sheriff's Department, public safety. But if you look
at what the city's done— You're amazing. Look at our parks, look at our,
uh, Uh, walking paths. Even behind
my house, which is a new build for the most part, it's all gone to
crap. It looks unpresentable,
ugly on the eye, and I don't
think that a 220% increase is going to help with that because
the problem's more within of like looking
of what we need to do to improve. Uh, there's countless times
I see Eagle Mountain City trucks just parked, not doing anything,
with employees just sitting there.
And I don't think that's right. If you have employees that are overworked,
I understand, but for someone to be overworked but
yet sitting in a parking lot not doing anything, that's not being overworked,
that's being lazy, and they got to be held accountable.
But I just wanted to add my 2 cents to this, and I don't
think that this is going to help us. I think it's going to hurt us
as a community to where we grow further apart. Thank you.
Okay, I don't see any other hands raised. I don't see
anyone in person and no emails. Is that correct?
Correct. All right. Oh wait,
we have one more, one more in person, right?
No.
Yes? No? Oh yes.
Okay.
Friends, colleagues, good to see you guys.
Um, yeah, I just I quickly will say,
it's hard to squeeze money from people who have no money, but we do have
companies of global wealth income like Facebook and Google.
So it's better to try to get some strategy plans to see
what they can do because they could easily cover whatever you guys need versus squeezing
these people out. So that's just a good strategy. We could talk about
how to get a plan to see all these new companies
coming in, all all these new companies coming in, how to structure
that deal better. Kind of like the citizens in Alaska from the gold and oil,
the citizens actually get money back.
And so I do believe in the natural growth to
kind of let that natural income come as, you know, people are
moving in every week into this town. So just strategies like that.
So you guys are doing great. We'll talk. Thanks.
Can you state your name for the record, please? Yeah, for the record, James Russell.
Thank you.
Okay, I don't see anyone else still. And again,
I know we want to make sure everybody's had a chance to speak. So is
that everyone? We did receive one email. I don't recognize the name,
Lee Kim, that they want to make known that I'm against the increase.
No transparency is being had.
Okay, all of the emails. I don't see any hands
raised or anyone coming forward at this time.
Last chance. Okay, I don't see anybody. So at
9:00 PM August 6th, we'll close this public
hearing. Um, at this time, I'd like to read our proposed property
tax impact schedule. Uh, this is just the
proposed schedule. It's, uh, what's been in front of people. I've read it in almost
every single meeting. for quite some time now. So,
uh, just for some understanding, the proposed property tax impact schedule
is Eagle Mountain City will consider an increase to its property tax rate to
generate an additional $6,742,938.
The following information is intended to provide a decision— the decision
makers and the public with an explanation of how cities op— how
how the city operations would be affected if
the proposed property tax increase is adopted.
Property tax rate with no increase is 0.000530.
Property tax revenue with no increase,
$3,055,201.
Proposed revenue with tax change,
$9,798,139.
Increased revenue to Eagle Mountain City,
$6,742,938.
Eagle Mountain City's 2026
proposed property tax rate,
0.001700. Estimated increase to Eagle Mountain City's property tax revenue,
220.88%. Estimated increase to the average primary resident
market value, $488,000. Estimated tax
increase, $314.03.
Total city tax, $5— or sorry,
$456.28.
Estimated increase to average businesses market value,
$2,554,303.
Estimated tax increase, $2,987.84.
Total city tax, $4,341.62.
The affected budget, sheriff's contract. The proposed
budget is $9,798,139.
The budget with no tax change is $8,290,000,
and the budget change would be $1,507,000.
$939. If a new property tax increase
is approved, the revenue will be used to fund essential public safety operations at
the level approved by the City Council. These funds will help
support core functions of the Utah County Sheriff's Office Eagle Mountain Division,
including the addition of deputies to meet the growth of the city.
That is the proposed property tax impact schedule.
Thank you for, uh, listening to that. I appreciate everybody
that's made their comments. I think, as is our custom, I want
to bring this back to the council and allow each of you to address
maybe some of the notes you've made before we start our deliberation. I would,
however, ask, and maybe counsel
with my fellow council members in the same respect of the public
that they've had only 3 minutes to speak, that at this time you each limit
your comments to maybe 3 minutes and try to address some
of the questions or any of the the ideas that you have, and then we
will have also additional time to, uh,
deliberate on, on the item in front of us. But I just wanted to give
everybody a chance to, uh, to speak concerning the public hearing
and, uh, any council, uh, questions or concerns.
So, uh, I think I'm going to start on my right, which is
Zach. Councilmember Dewish, if you want to address public— Yes, follow up.
Do you have a timer for me? Okay. Would you
like a timer? I can do a timer. I would like a timer, please.
I've got more than 3 minutes. Okay, go ahead. But I'll keep this part
to 3 minutes. First, I wanna say I'm sorry that you're here.
I am grateful that you all showed up. For those that have come, the gentleman
that was up at 2:30 this morning and got off work at 4:30 to be
here, I'm sorry that you're here. Quite frankly,
I don't want to be here. I don't want to be in this chair.
I threw my hat in the ring for Mayor Gray's city council seat because we
have had compounded serial missteps in our city for
several years. I've lived here over 20 years, and quite frankly,
we, we need to step it up as leaders in the city.
I'm hearing 4 themes. One is affordability, which maybe
I'll, I'll address a little bit later. Transparency— we
failed you. We absolutely failed you. I took it into my own hands
to, to do a podcast. It's hard to communicate effectively
to a city of 80,000 people. The citizens page, I just didn't
feel like was a good way to communicate in, in sound
bites. There's been a lot of miscommunication. It's been
told that this was passed unanimously. It was not passed
unanimously. It was. Even though that's out on the citizens page, so I tried to
put a podcast out at my own expense to try to build context.
I've put my phone number out there. I've I've had
five or six residents reach out to me personally. I've had ten to fifteen
emails, and I'm just grateful that we are here tonight.
Even though none of us wanted to be here, I'm grateful that we are here.
This process allows everyone to share their thoughts, their feelings,
and it's scary to come up. To the pulpit in front of the dais.
I've stood there myself. The second thing
is the policy, which we're going to come back to. I want to spend more
time there. And then third, the data centers. That has been one
of those compounding things. The state has floated,
or policymakers at the state have floated, the idea of socializing
the MET tax that we've all talked about, that we've all been counting on
and told that we're going to have this tax. There is a
policy that was not passed, was defeated,
that would essentially take the municipal energy tax and socialize it to other
cities. In my mind, that's wrong. We've been waiting.
We've been, you know, promised that that tax would come back to our city.
So there are very active, real threats around
revenue to our city, and we're trying to manage that as best we can along
with the, with the caps. I don't
know that this is the right rate. Um, I didn't vote for
this in the first round, and I'm, I'm hoping to have a lively discussion
with everyone tonight. Thank you for being here.
Councilmember Wood. Go ahead, start my timer.
Thank you for speaking. I think everybody here that knows me or that
has listened to me knows that We're not afraid to hear your words. We want
to hear everything that you feel. And sometimes we get stuff wrong.
I mean, that's just the reality. I would tell you the number one highlighted thing—
I share your frustration. I think we did a horrible job of communication.
I, I think that's been highlighted by every person here. And so
for that, I want to apologize. And I don't remember who the gentleman was that
said it was our responsibility to communicate that. I think it was one of the
people online. I will own that.
I should have communicated. To Zach's
point, it is difficult to find a method that we can reach
to people and get truthful information out. There is so much
disinformation that is out there. It's in the media,
the social media outlet. Go to the Eagle Mountain Citizens
page. There's not— there's very little truth in anything that's being said in there.
And I debated, how do I get the information
to people? How do I tell them why I'm interested in voting for
a tax increase of any size? We're gonna have a chance
to talk about that, and I wanna address that at that point. But I agree
that there are the 4 things that we need to talk about. What is real
with data center money? What are the challenges that we're facing from the state in
their efforts to try to raise additional revenue? Additional funds at our expense?
What are some of the laws that have been floated that were defeated that
we know are coming back? And then I think I definitely
want to talk about the way that we communicate with you. I've been very frustrated
with that long before I was ever on this council, and I don't think it's
improved all that much, frankly. I think that the information
that you expected, I would expect if I was in your seat, and we didn't
provide that information to you. And I will address that in that latter part.
Thank you for taking the time. It's a great sacrifice for you to be here.
That's not lost on me. I appreciate you being here so we can actually have
a dialogue and explain to you some of the things that we're thinking about and
where I'm gonna land is not predetermined.
I will tell you, I'm not sure where I'm gonna be at the end of
this. We did have to make a decision to be able to
have this discussion. So we started with what are our actual needs,
and I'd like an opportunity to be able to explain that to you.
Thank you. Councilmember Whiting. Thank you so much for
being here. We really, really appreciate you. We appreciate all the comments.
We appreciate you that you've stayed here already for over 3 hours,
and we hope you can stay for the duration
of the commentary here. There's been a lot of questions asked. There's a lot of
information that's going to come back your direction.
Skepticism of government is a highly healthy thing,
and I encourage it. I applaud it, and I hope the Eagle Mountain City— the
citizens here will ever remain skeptical of government, whether it's local
or state or federal. We need to do that. We've had so much experience
in the past where there has been fraud and abuse at the
levels of government. We've experienced that even recently in the last couple
weeks. For those paying attention to hearings
in Washington, D.C., we have learned that the federal government
was deceitful on numerous levels and numerous
occasions with how it handled the COVID situation.
We are learning that Dr. Fauci in his private diary was saying one
thing and publicly saying something completely different. That affected public
policy in a significant way. The social distancing was a lie.
There is no science behind it. Dr. Fauci admits that. That's what
shut down our businesses. That's what shut down our schools. That's what shut down our
churches. And that is what led to massive inflation.
That's what led to significant costs we are now experiencing.
But I only bring that up because skepticism
is healthy. You need to come before us and say, you guys need to document
this, that, and the other. You have the right to know. You need to make
sure that we're not doing the same thing that other government leaders have done.
So I applaud that you're here. The only thing that's sad about it
is we only have a few of you here. There are so many online that
will get their information from social media where there are only half-truths,
or people think they have the truth and lead a whole garrison of people the
wrong direction. So I hope you'll stay so we can have a dialogue that can
that can be healthy, where we can transmit information as to why would we consider
an increase? Why would we do something that would be unpopular? Why would we want
to do that? It would be easy for any of us to
be the single champion and have a whole— people rally behind us.
Why would we consider the tax increase? So I hope you'll stay so we can
have additional discussion, and I really appreciate again that you're here. Thank you.
Okay, thank you. Councilmember Wright, go ahead. Thank you, Mayor.
It's been good to hear from you.
Um, somebody said that we're going to take the easy way out. I can assure
you this is not the easy way out. Um,
the easy way out is really ignoring the needs that the city is experiencing,
the growth that we're, that we're, that we're dealing with.
The loss of employees because we can't keep
them even in a median area as far as payroll goes.
There's a lot that we need to discuss, but I do want to thank you
for coming. I appreciate you sharing your thoughts. I really
hope you'll listen to the discussion that's going to ensue because I
don't get the feeling, I haven't had the feeling that that this is settled in
an exact place, but we're going to have some
dialogue and some discussion about it. But I am
absolutely considering a tax increase
for all of the right reasons. And some of you are going to shake your
heads and say, well, what are the right reasons? We're going to have that discussion.
It's not the easy way out. In fact, it's the most difficult path that we
have to take forward. The easy way is to say we're not going to do
anything, and what we're going to do is just continue to reduce services, and we're
not going to take care of those things that we, that we own and that
we should be taking care of. And that's what we've done for a number of
years. It's always tighten your belt, figure out a way forward without
dealing with the hard problems of the fact that we
don't have the resources that we need to take care of those things that we
have. It really is a resourcing problem.
And I can assure you this, this city council and those of
the very short past have been anxiously engaged in creating economic
development that is going to bear fruit.
I'm confident of that. And you shake your heads no,
and you can disbelieve that, but the day will come when Eagle Mountain will
be known as one of the most I
want to use the right word— prosperous cities
in Utah County, certainly, and within the state of Utah.
Those days are on our horizon, but they are not today.
They are coming. And I know Mayor Gray's gotten in trouble for saying
that, and I'm going to do you a favor.
I'm started— I've started into my second term. This is my
5th year. I'm not going to rerun.
I am here to do— 30 seconds remaining. And to make the right decisions
and to make the changes. And we have said no. We have
said no on multiple occasions, in multiple ways, and made very hard decisions.
We've adjusted the way development happens in Eagle Mountain, the way the water
is allocated. We have made some tremendous strides in holding
the development community accountable when they were not being held accountable prior
to my arrival here.
I'm sure we'll talk a little bit more about that. My time's about out,
but thank you for being here.
Okay, yeah, go ahead, uh, Councilor McClark. Thank you
all for being here tonight. Um, I totally get
why people are angry, and it makes sense that you're mistrustful,
and it even makes sense why maybe you're a little bit afraid that your quality
of life and your ability to take care of your family and provide for
for their needs could change. And the fact is, is I feel
all of those same things. Before I ran for
city council, I was pissed that the city was spending money on
a park that I didn't think we had money for.
And I would rant and rave on Facebook, and I would tag all my elected
officials and ask them to be accountable for all of that.
And As I got
into office, I started to realize that there's way more
than I ever could have comprehended.
And frankly, serving the city's an
honor, but it's also super hard because
there were a lot of decisions made in the early years of the city that
set us up for for a trajectory that makes it
so that we don't have as much control now.
I want you to know too that this isn't settled. I spent a lot
of time going through budgets. I spent a lot of time going through what our
city's doing, what other cities are doing, and trying to
find ways that we could save money so that we don't have to raise taxes.
But like my colleagues up here have said, it would be easy for us
just to say no and not look at the real needs that we
have as a city. I think the biggest thing that we have to figure
out tonight while we're meeting with you guys is what
do we cut? What are the priorities that matter the
most to the people of our community? Because there's
more needs than we have money. Thank you. We do need to do a better
job of communicating. Mayor Gray and this
council have tried to come to your
neighborhoods and do a listening tour. We've tried to go to
farmers markets, but it's still not enough. It's still not enough,
and we need to
do better. I want to thank you all for being
here. I hope that we get an opportunity to talk about
some of the history, some of the changes, some of the reasons
for the things that we do. 30 seconds remaining. Um,
and I hope that you guys get a chance to stay and be a part
of that conversation. So thank you.
Okay, now something a little different. Uh, council kind
of knew that they were going to get a chance, and as they always do,
uh, but this part maybe they didn't know. I'm just going to ask, you can
say no, Our City Manager Ben Reeves has
been a great addition to our city and has a wealth of knowledge.
I'm just going to ask if there are any comments that you'd like to
make and if there's any maybe clarifying things or anything
that you can help the public or the council. And you can
say no. And following that, I do know that Sheriff Smith is also in the
audience and give him a chance to represent the Sheriff's
Department if he wishes. Uh, I don't mean to put you on the spot,
but I just wanted to, to lay that out there.
Thank you, Mayor. And, and I echo the comments of the council,
and I echo the, the fact that it is a great honor to serve
this community. Um, I've been here just a short time,
and, um, but I've seen, uh, Eagle Mountain City from afar
for— since its inception back in 1996 when 250
residents came together to, to collectively work to build towards a brighter
future. And today here we are inheriting,
um, 80— a city of 80,000, and, and yet the
services and the, the work and the infrastructure and everything that is
needed is so essential in order to enhance and protect and
preserve the quality of life that you've enjoyed for these last 30 years.
Coming in new, I, I just look
and applaud at our, our first responders, both with the
Sheriff's Department and with, with UFA and our city staff
and all that they do. And I— it's what's hard for me is that I
truly feel like for many, many years that they've been working with basically
an arm tied behind their back. We haven't invested in them.
And, and I think there is a, a strong desire for, you know,
the, the mentality of use it up, wear it out, make it do what it
do without. And that's great. But there's also a certain expectation that our property
values go down if we don't take care of our open spaces, if we don't
take care of our parks. People go to other areas.
I know it was talked a lot about the data centers. I wasn't here when
the first data center was approved, but I can tell you that the incentives
given to the first data center brought the next, and then that brought the next.
And with each subsequent data center to today, there's been
less incentive, less incentive to that. There's no incentives today, and,
and they're going the other direction and bringing money to the table
up front. And so if it wasn't for some of the decisions of the past,
we wouldn't have inherited the bright future as well. And so it's
hard to stand in judgment for those who have been here before, but I can
tell you today that our city staff is about the third of the
size of city staff of equivalent population,
and they are working their hearts out, and they care, and they,
they, they love the city that they work for, they love the council that they
work for, and they love serving the people that they work for. And yet it's
hard to hear after day after day that, you know,
we suck, we're not keeping up, we're not keeping the parks up, we're not keeping
the trails up. Well, we can only do what we can do with the staff
that we have, and we can only provide that level of service that
we can afford to accomplish. 30 seconds remaining. And so ultimately,
this is a policy decision, and I will support the council in whatever they
do, and I am absolutely confident our staff will support the council in whatever they
decide, and they will do the very best with whatever resources that you entrust
to them. But at the same time, please recognize
that we're in it together. We are one team. We're one family. We're one Eagle
Mountain City. We all live here. We all want to see our kids and grandkids
live here in the future as well. Thank you.
I can't see Sheriff Smith off the screen, but is he— there
he is. Yep. Thank you,
Mayor. Super excited to speak at something like this.
So, so hey, I, you know, honestly, I get PTSD
with these type of meetings. I hate them. I feel for
everybody that spoke tonight. My heart goes out
to you. It's a horrible thing. I feel for the council. It's a
tough decision. It's easy to armchair
quarterback this and criticize, but I can
tell you, as somebody who sits in the seat also, it's It's a whole different
story when you're sitting in the seat and you have to make the decision.
So I respect that. I respect
you for what you're doing. And what I will say as the sheriff is we
are extremely proud to be
your law enforcement out in
Eagle Mountain. We are Eagle Mountain out here.
The deputies that we send out here are The finest
deputies that we have in the sheriff's office. You are getting high-quality
people. We're able to, through the sheriff's office, we're able to recruit
top officers. A lot of times, you know, I get chiefs that are mad at
me. We're taking them from other cities because they want to come work for
the sheriff's office. And so Eagle Mountain benefits from that.
And what I will tell you is it's a
tough decision to come to Eagle Mountain Council and say, hey, we need
this. But as we look at crime, as we look at the growth of this
city, I'll tell you, as far as the truth in
taxation and what it costs to do it, again,
that's a really tough decision. But that's not what I look
at. I look at how do we keep Eagle Mountain safe? How do we keep
Eagle Mountain a community that people want to move
to, that people feel comfortable living in, that people feel like
their public safety is doing their jobs. I come out and I campaign.
I go to meetings and I'll tell you what I hear, not in
a Truth in Taxation meeting, but what I hear overwhelmingly from people
is they're upset. They're upset because they called on,
you know, maybe something lower level
on the food chain of law enforcement and they didn't get the response they needed.
Why aren't you guys responding? And I can tell you the reason why is is
because the, the deputies are basically going from call
to call to call. And I heard a few comments tonight about, well, we saw
them getting a drink at 7-Eleven or wherever they were. And I've
told them, and I challenge them, I'm like, if you have downtime, I would rather
have you— 30 seconds remaining— instead of coming to the office and hanging out,
I would rather have you going somewhere like that to take a break and
talk to the community, be out there with the community. So we,
we want to be your police force. And what I will, what I will guarantee
you as your sheriff is we're not asking for anything that's not needed out
here. It is, it is definitely needed. Actually, more is needed.
I've heard a few comments about doing your own police.
That's on the table if they want, but I think the council knows in a
feasibility study that is nowhere— it's not— Your time is up. Thank you. It's not
even close to what you're getting for your Okay,
thank you. And I will add a couple comments I forgot to do
earlier. But some of the things like that
were brought up in the meeting, impact fees and grants, those are all one-time monies.
These deputies that we hire will be ongoing expenses year over year with their
salaries. Just, just as thoughts for some of the questions that were
brought up. Thank you. Also, I work extensively with our
data center partners. I've been in office now 213 days,
and I've got to know those guys very, very well.
And I did— in the course of the week, I wanted to know some of
the actual numbers for the community to understand. And QTS
actually provided some talking points just to— You guys can take
these numbers back and look at what it is that we've been telling you Coming.
They're under construction. And so these, these haven't been
fully realized yet. But the property tax impact from QTS,
they're committed to building within our city. In the new buildings, there's 3
buildings that are under construction right now. They're looking to break ground on 2 more
buildings just to the north. The impact will generate over
$19 million a year for our local jurisdictions.
And Evan obviously knows these numbers, and we're going
through these numbers every day. Yeah. Just for Eagle Mountain City alone, in our current
tax rate, that Eagle Mountain City, that would be $2.7 million a
year. The Utah County would get $1.7 million.
Here's the big one. I heard of this a lot during this, you know,
the concerns about the school district. Lake Mountain School District on the
current high building would get $10.4 million a year. That's an
additional $10.4 million for the budget. Every 3 years that builds an
elementary school. So when I mentioned earlier on that
this money is coming, these are the actual numbers. Unified Fire District
under the current taxing system would get $3.2 million. We're looking by next
year to bring that taxing authority back in-house. Add that to the
city amount and you would see a little over $5 million to
the city rather than the $2.7 million. So those are the
kind of numbers Utah Central Water District would get. Okay. We get almost $1
million, and then the other districts just shy of $500,000.
Another thing is QTS was granted some tax
incentives when they started those first 3 buildings. They came back on these next 2—
we didn't even ask this— and said, hey, by the way, you guys have been
so great to us, we don't want any incentives on these next builds. Just,
we're going to be full taxpayers starting day one. So I want that to
soak in a little bit that We are negotiating and we are
working with these people, and they are going to contribute
right around the corner. These dollars are going to be realized right away.
We haven't even talked about the MET that that also generates. So,
and another point, we were trying to figure out how to widen
Pony Express here a couple of weeks ago. QTS,
I made one phone call to them and said, hey, maybe we could do a
reimbursement agreement, like how to work this out. That was some ideas talked about
in the city hall. I called them and said, you know what, I don't feel
like this is a burden the residents should bear. Some of that traffic on
Pony Express is because of their workers. I said, it's about a $5 million
bill with 2 stoplights, and 2 of those stoplights are areas that turn towards
their development. It's about a $5 million ask,
and I asked them to consider helping us
with that, at least half or most. Uh, the,
the people that are charged with making those decisions said,
give me just a minute, hung the phone up and called me right back and
said, you know what, not only will we help, we'll pay for that entire $5
million bill. That road will be built. So now our internal staff,
our engineers are working hard to make sure that we can get that as soon
as possible. I think we'll see some of it this year and some in the
future. So I just want you to know that these data centers are invested in
our community. Thank you. And not just at their site, but in areas where
we direct that we need some help. So, uh,
some of those numbers are now out there, and you're welcome
to get further information. I would say those
are estimated a little bit, but we've done a lot of math over the last
week just so that we can provide that with some fairly good confidence that that's
the direction that we're headed on just that one site. Right.
That does not include some of the other data centers. So I just wanted
to get that out there as we move forward in this discussion. I think
it's time— I just want to reach out to Marcus,
Lacey. I know Kimberly's there. Procedurally, if we missed anything
that we need to address at this time before I go on to item number
4, or the council.
Uh, looks like we are okay. Marcus, Kimberly, and I,
we have everything we need. Thank you. I think we're good.
Okay, and if the council has any questions or as we move forward,
you're welcome to let me know, but I think it's time we move on
to item number 4 on our agenda, which is a resolution of Eagle Mountain City
approving a property tax increase above the
certified tax rate for fiscal year '26-'27.
I think we've talked about this a lot through our budget process and
whatnot. So at this time, I'd just like to turn it over to the council
if you have any questions or comments. I know there are a few of you
that said that you want to get into a little more detail at this point.
Uh, so I'm open to,
uh, raise your hand, let me know if you'd like to speak, and we'll
try to be as orderly as possible. Again, I appreciate you guys allowing me to
do this remotely, but whoever wants to speak, uh, Let me know.
Mayor, really quick, I think you guys have asked the question about
transparency, and you're like, we want a line-by-line,
uh, explanation of the budget and what the money's being
spent on. And I want you guys to know that that
document exists. And not only does that document exist right now for this
year's budget, but it exists for all of the previous year's budgets,
and they are all on our city website. There's an
interactive budget so you can kind of see what the goals are
for every single department, what their projects are that they're working
on. So if it's parks, what parks they're upgrading.
If it's the attorney's office, what contracts and different
things they're working on. And it's important to us that
you guys know today when you go home that that exists,
and we are 100% transparent and
accountable to you guys. We want you to know that it's out there. We've done
a crappy job of helping you know where it is,
but it exists. And I think it's really important
for you guys to know that it's there. Thanks.
Yeah, I think to your point, a lot of people have used the word transparency
instead of communication. Transparency, everything that we've done has been in
an open and public meeting, and it's very transparent.
What it isn't is easy to get it out to the public in
a form maybe easy to understand or whatnot. So the communication side,
we've done our best, and we try, and we improve every day. But transparency is
definitely— everything we've done has been in the open. So.
Next, is that Council Member Hewish? You go ahead.
Yeah, I just want to go, go deeper into the transparency piece.
When the— this is my understanding, and, and Ben, you can correct
me if I misstep anywhere, okay? I'm going to be careful.
But when the application was submitted for the policy to cover 100%
of the sheriff's contract 100% with property taxes.
That was the application. And in the state
of Utah, to vary from that application would completely
disrupt this entire process. So you have the communication
that was put out to
communicate the policy, but it's obvious that you take
$6.7 million minus roughly $1.5 million
and there's a gap there. It's like, well, what happens with that money,
right? And that's not part of the initial application. That's a separate
discussion. So I want to, if it's okay to talk
about— It's okay. All right. I just want to be clear. This is something that
I also struggled with in understanding and trying to communicate. So some
of the things as a council that we've talked about,
there are several projects going on within the city. There's also
several staffing shortfalls. Number one,
we've talked about getting our staff to 90%.
I believe it's 90% of the median. Is that correct, Ben?
We're not there. Our staff is underpaid. My neighbor used to
work in the city of Eagle Mountain. He now drives to Herriman. They just pay
more. He makes more money there. He is excellent with concrete
work, and we train people up. We hire them here. We train them
and then we lose them to other cities. And the cost of training is expensive.
If for those of you that are business owners, it's expensive to train people and
it's painful when you lose them because of salary.
So part of the contemplation with the freed
up funds is to increase based
on merit and getting people up to that level to where they're
not even above average, but at,
at the 90% of the median, of the
middle. Okay, so not even there. That cost is about $525,000
to do that. So there's that. There's also
the contemplation. These, these are positions that would impact
the general fund. There's about 18
part-time and full-time positions. 13 of those,
in my estimation, have to do with our parks. And I'm just gonna— I won't
go through each specific salary, but I would like to mention,
uh, the, the different jobs. So we, we've contemplated,
uh, hiring 3 open space,
uh, employees for— So when
you're on Eagle Mountain Citizens page and you see someone complaining about My trail needs
to be cleaned. We've got trails all over. We've got,
I don't know, hundreds of miles of trail. I have them behind my
house and they get overgrown. And we've, we've got a staff where
that's what they're out doing. We've contemplated having
3 parks technicians. The other
day I was at Quarry Ride, and I'm sorry if I'm going— is it okay?
Go. Okay. I just have a lot to say. I've been thinking
about this a lot. I was at Corey Ride at the dunk tank
actually yesterday with the Youth Council, and I was walking around the park and I
was like, the grass actually looks good. The last time I was Corey
Ride, it looked terrible. And I thought, we sold our utility for this park and
we just let it go. And I happened to run into one of the parks
techs that was there. I said, you've got—
this park looks good. I don't know what you're doing, but it does not look
like the park by my house. The park by my house is dying. There's weeds
everywhere, and you can drive around Eagle Mountain and see
those conditions. And he said, you know, we took this park back in-house,
meaning our employees are taking care of this park. We have a lot
of contract work that happens throughout the city in our parks,
and they don't look great. So we've contemplated hiring
more parks crews so that we can actually control the quality and service level.
Thank you. We've considered
recreation.
We have brought soccer back in-house. So our
ball fields, our soccer fields are not in great condition.
Some of the kids that are playing are skinning their knees. Maybe that's
okay. For me, I think we can do better there. We've also contemplated
a streets operator, sealing the cracks. Now it's true when you build a development
and you charge impact fees to a developer, that developer is
not on the hook for the maintenance in perpetuity. There's just not a fund that
exists to maintain those streets, and there are
real costs. So we've contemplated hiring there. There's also 5 positions
considered around engineering
and just day-to-day operations. We have a lot of Well,
Ben can probably speak to this, to turnover within the city regarding
HR. Our purchasing agent is overwhelmed.
Last year asked for— to hire somebody.
We did not hire that person. She's working a lot of overtime,
and, you know, it's emotionally exhausting. So these
are some of the things that freed up funds
that we're contemplating. Thank you. This was
in the May 26th meeting. I talked about this specifically.
And you can go listen to those. I know nobody wants to go listen to
6 hours of budget meetings of city council. That's not your job. That's our job.
But these are things that weren't communicated, I think out of a fear of
crossing the line with the application that was filled.
So I just want to clarify that. And if there's anything that
I communicated in in the podcast that I put out there was not intended to
mislead anybody or to confuse anyone. It was meant to bring
more context that I didn't feel like was being put out there in, um,
in the Eagle Mountain Citizens page. So I'll just pause there on transparency,
and I have more around policy that I'd love to discuss.
Yeah, and I think the, the key to that, Zach, what you're talking about
is, uh, more about the budget and the budget process than,
than so much this tax, but just all of the different things in our budget
that we are dealing with, right? So appreciate the context.
Um, I think Councilmember Wood, you had some other comments,
or Councilmember Whiting, go ahead. Yep, thank you, Mayor.
So we were asked earlier to answer the question,
what are the, you know, 3 capital projects you would spend the money
on? And I'm going to jump on what Councilmember Hewish already
indicated, that our parks and open space, it's very apparent. You just drive around and
you see their condition. So, so before
I answer the question, that, that question, let me back up and support something.
So when we, when we say that 100% of the public,
of the, the property tax increase goes to public safety, that is the
correct answer. What we need to do is, is help you
understand, and this, this means we didn't communicate this well enough,
how public safety has been paid. So right now it's being paid for
through property tax, and we're essentially robbing from sales
tax to help subsidize our
police and our public safety. So this communication
that we're— that 100% of the tax increase goes to public safety is
true. Now puts property tax as the pillar upon which public safety
now stands. And this is what we need to communicate better. What that now does
is is it, it, it takes the,
the sales tax dollars that we were essentially robbing from sales tax to
go support public safety, and now it takes that sales tax dollars to do other
things. And that's what Councilmember Herwish was referring to, the several different hires
within the city, wage increases for the employees.
And, and so that's— and perhaps that's what some of you are wondering,
like, okay, what is now, uh, what can now be paid
for? Property tax is now taken public safety, what can we now do with sales
tax dollars that were being used toward public safety, what can we now do
with them? We're stating some of it. If you go back and look at our
budgets, we said in the budget what we would do with that money, including several
understaffed departments. Our city
manager commented we're about a third the staffing level as
other cities of our size. With that being said,
these dollars that are available now through sales tax. My number one
thing is public safety on our streets.
We have a massive need right now for safer streets,
especially in our school zones. And we need, we need speed tables
and other mechanisms to keep the kids safe. It may
shock you, but a speed table costs about $70,000 to $80,000.
And we don't just need one. We don't just need two. We need
a ton of them. That costs a lot of money.
If this tax— this doesn't go through, what now happens? Well, the sales
tax will have to go back to support, you know, our public safety,
and it gets diverted from being able to put speed tables and other things like
that in our school zones and other streets. There was comment
that I know, you know, there's some of you that I know well that have
come up and made public comment. I know that you live on streets
that are not safe. Your streets are being studied right
now. We commissioned a study that is being done on
sensitive streets in the city, and so that we can get the best data
available on how to bring those cities to
a safer level, so we can slow down traffic,
so kids can cross safely. And that again goes
back to transparency. I think that's a message we didn't clearly communicate
well enough to the city, because had that been part of the
discussion, I think people would be like, oh, wait a second, I can get
behind freeing up some sales tax dollars to
go toward making sure our streets are safer. We just didn't
communicate that, which is why I'm happy you're here. This is part of the discussion
we can now have. to help educate and
get the information out there as to what we're doing and why
this increase is so important. I'll leave it at that for the time being.
I've got comments on— well, maybe let me just say this so I
can wrap up. I just had one additional comment on the data center thing.
We're hearing people saying, we're not seeing anything from the data centers. I'm gonna tell
you something. You are wrong, and I'll tell you why. Everyone,
in this city who is 100%— 120%
area median income or lower can qualify for
a down payment to buy a house.
That money is coming from data centers so
that you can— that down payment money just doesn't magically appear. It is Facebook,
and I believe Tyson, that's putting money into an
RDA from which we are— we have created the most successful
down payment mortgage down payment assistance program in the state.
It gives you more money and is more easily qualified for than any
other city. And maybe that again comes down to communication.
That is available. There's millions of dollars that's already been given
to citizens of Eagle Mountain to buy homes. Down payment is not
something that anybody needs to buy a home in this city. You don't need that.
If you're saying, I don't have a down payment, the down payment is available through
the RDAs that was set up that our data centers are funding
into. And it's only going to get bigger.
We just approved— and this is another conversation, and I'll probably talk about this later
in the meeting— part of the reason why we arrived to
the, to the area, to this situation, circumstance that we have arrived to, is we
have built the city upon residential housing.
And the challenge that owner-occupied residential housing, which I support,
but owner-occupied housing gets a 45% decrease on their
taxes. And so the
growth issue is one reason why I ran. I've been on the city council for
a few months now, by the way. And so that— not that it's
relevant or irrelevant, but I've been on here just a few months. Thank you.
I got involved because of growth that was unsustainable.
And so what happens is when prior city councils— I'm not going
to accuse them of their decisions, but they made decisions where they granted
developers the ability to build thousands of homes
at the fastest pace they want to build. There's 25,000
vested units that still exist that we can't get rid of.
And those can be built whenever those developers want to build it.
And so once you give the blank check to the developers
to be able to build as fast as they want to build, how can we
then manage the growth? Because they can build as fast as they want.
And when they build, yeah, we're collecting impact fees. But— and that came
up a lot too tonight— impact fees, we are charging them.
And guess what? We're charging as much as we're allowed to charge. I would love
for impact fees to pay for all of this stuff. The state of Utah has
laws about how impact fees can be charged. We're charging the maximum we can charge.
I'm just letting you all know that. But, but those impact fees, the state has
come in for whatever reasons it's come in and curbed how
much we can charge. So we charge as much as we can. But is it
enough? It's not enough. But we are, we are charging as much as we can.
So when citizens come up and say, what about impact fees? It's true that
we should ask that question. We're charging what we can charge, but the impact
is clearly not being paid for correctly, right? I mean,
there's— they're creating more impact than we can collect.
But anyway, I bring this up because you
need to know that this city council this year— I want
you to guess how many new housing units has
this city council approved? Zero. We have approved
33 total.
Is growth being managed? It's being managed. How many
developers have— just Twasik alone, I had 2 developers
reach out to me privately, not to these— to my fellow city council members.
Craig, I want to do this high-density development here. I want to do this development
here. And I said, it's not the time and it's not going to happen.
We're not going to support it. It's not going to happen. And they just— and
they left. You don't see the gates that we are
defending. We are defending this castle right now in a way that I can't
say hasn't ever been defended before. But since I've been involved here and the city
council has been unified in this, we are managing residential growth
exceptionally well because it's these— it's the
additional residents that are coming in paying 2010 taxes that
we cannot sustain. That math does not add up when we're
charging those new residents, those new households, 2010 taxes And
we're trying to support them through 2026 expenses. Every new resident
that comes in, we cannot sustain it.
There are not— there's not enough being collected from the new households. The growth— you're
saying, well, we have a larger tax base. Revenues have increased because we have a
larger tax base, but expenses have increased much faster.
So when people say the growth should pay for it, the growth is the issue
because we are growing under a 2010 tax rate.
Even the data centers say, well, get the data centers to pay more money.
I would love if we could tax the data centers separately. The state of
Utah doesn't allow it. I would love to do it. We cannot
do that. It's illegal to do that. So guess what? The data centers,
if they had sent a representative here, would have also been standing at the very
pulpit you stood at and would have said, we oppose the tax increase.
They would have all done that. They are laughing
all the way to the bank right now that they are only paying 2010
taxes, and the only way we can make them pay more is to
increase the tax rate. And that tax rate has to be increased on
that same tax rate that we, that we could vote on today. That applies
ubiquitously across the city. That's the only way to
get them to pay more. I wish we could get them to pay more otherwise.
We just cannot. And so it's, it's important for
us to know that growth, unsustainable.
That has caused us to be in the situation we're at today where
we suddenly have to make a decision that's difficult. Anyway, I will— I'll pass
the microphone down.
Mayor, are you okay if I talk? Yeah, go ahead. I just want to remind
the council too on item number 4, I mean, free to speak. I'm not limiting
debate necessarily. I'd just like to keep it to maybe
your position on the tax increase and supporting your position.
And I understand everything we've heard is in that manner,
but just to— With
all due respect, Mayor, I think that both of them have kept on topic with
why people are looking for answers as to what is motivating these
decisions. And I think we need to probably err on the side of
allowing the council to give an explanation. explanation of why we're going to tax people.
So that's exactly what I'm asking. Okay, what I said— I,
first of all, thank you to both of the council members who have expressed a
lot of the things that I think have been part
of the decision-making process for me. Um,
all of them will corroborate what I'm about to say. When we had this discussion,
uh, and, uh, I was actually remote It was a discussion that
began and probably ended with our
retreat in St. George. But one of the things that I said, and I still
stand by this, the only thing anybody's ever going to remember is 220%.
Doesn't matter what else we say.
The only thing they're going to hear is 220%. So we have to
be concise and clear about how we
express to them why that even makes any sense to anybody.
The reason that I voted for us to put that certified tax
rate at the level that it was is because I believe a fiscal responsibility
to fund our police force, our public safety, with a
stable revenue. That is not sales tax.
And I, I appreciate the head shakes. I do. Because let me explain that
to you, because I want you to understand where I'm coming from.
What happened when the pandemic happened and sales tax wasn't providing
anything for anybody? Did we just stop having police force?
What happened when the market crashed and
everybody started losing their houses? Did we suddenly not have a need for police force?
In fact, we had a greater need for police force. There isn't a single
person who lives in this city that does not pay a property tax of some
sort that goes directly to the police force
under this particular proposal. Perhaps the
rate's wrong, but I think in principle, a stable revenue
source to pay for public safety should be a principle that we stand on.
We have been woefully arrogant,
and we have been,
I'm not going to be loose with our lack
of financial plans in this city. We haven't had one.
When I got here, I said, where's our 5-year plan? Where's our 10-year plan?
Do we have a 20-year plan? The answer is no to all
of those things. So when you're asking how come you can't
provide that information, I'm asking the same thing. Where is the information
that we're making these decisions on, and how are we preparing for the future.
I, I think it's interesting when you have past council members come
in and say things like, uh, how, how dare you did that, we were able
to live on the income that we had there. And I think we're here
because of your irresponsibility. You left this
big pile for us. You didn't raise fees for
water, you didn't raise fees for sewer, almost to the point where we're in
the red. You didn't raise property taxes because of
some crazy conservative fiscal federal mentality
of I'm not going to raise taxes because somehow money appears
out of nowhere. And it left us in a position where we
hear you when you say our parks are in poor repair,
our parkways are not being taken care of, I can't ride my motorcycle
down the road because all we can afford to do is crack seal.
We can't raise the level of How we're taking care
of the city because we don't have the funds to do so because people in
the past thought that being cheap was a good way of public
policy. So I find myself in this situation now
of how do we course correct this?
Some of you have said, how can we do it incrementally?
If you want to continue to kick the can down the road, we can do
that. You will find that we cannot keep on pace, exactly what Craig was
saying. Thank you. We are adding 1,800 building permits a year.
That is not sustainable for our roads, for our public safety,
for fire services. We're 50 square miles. There is
no other city that is experiencing the problems that we have with
basically 2 separate cities that existed forever with
nothing in between, and we had to service both with water,
sewer, public safety, fire services.
So we're left in this place with, well, what's the decision to be made
then? Everybody's going to hate the decision. If I came in and said in the
very beginning we're going to raise the taxes by 5%, would anybody raise their hand
and say, yeah, I'm in favor of you raising taxes? The answer
is going to be no. We're raising taxes. I'm against it. I don't
want to pay it. It affects me. We are a one-income family as well,
by the way. And it affects our ability to be able to make our bills
as well. I also pushed very, very hard to have a corridor
that goes behind my house that ruins the sight
and sound of my area I live in in Silver Lake that's quiet,
and it will not be that anymore. I also voted to make sure that we
built a road from Brookhaven up to the upper part of
Silver Lake out to Pony Express so there was a safe walking route for
the kids. And guess whose house that goes by? Mine.
I took all the traffic. It's not good for me. It's bad
for my family. My kids can't go out on the street, but it created an
opportunity for them to walk to school.
Craig brought up the speed tables. I think you need to know how
passionate we are about making sure that number one, every one of the elementary
schools has sufficient safe ways to stop traffic
so that they can cross. The crossing guards shouldn't have to feel like
they're going to get hit. And then we have a speed study that is going
to address every other road that has the same problem. We had a community come
in, uh, 2, 2 meetings ago talking about
the speed in their community, and they've been told multiple times, you know, we'll find
a solution, then nothing's happened. The one thing I want you to walk away from
this today, regardless of what our decision is, there isn't anybody
up here that is looking for an easy way out. I hope that
there isn't anybody that's trying to make the decisions for a political reason,
because I think that's a coward's way out. We should be doing what's right regardless
of the, of the outcome. And for me, that's how
I will vote. I'll vote for what is best for 80,000 people. I'm not
going to do what's best for a few.
Mayor, is it okay if I go? Yes, sir, please.
I would just echo everything that's been said. I think something that hasn't been hit
on is transportation. The biggest issue that we face in Eagle Mountain
is transportation and our transportation corridors. We sit in traffic
far too often and far too long. We have intersections that are missing,
uh, traffic control signals because we can't afford to put them in.
Where does that money come from? If we continue to pull sales
tax dollars, which could fund those, those infrastructure improvements, and we
continue to allocate it to our sheriff's contract or to our public services.
Those are the things that we're really facing. Every time that
we decide we need a road to be a little bit bigger, we've got to
upsize some sewer, we've got to do some sort of improvement,
that comes out of the taxpayers' dollars. It comes
out of the general fund, and we have to decide, are we going to set
some money aside take care of those improvements, or are we going to continue to
fund as it grows? Because I'm going to tell you this, should we
choose to approve this at 220% this year,
next year that is not going to cover 100% of the sheriff's contract.
News flash. Because their fuel is going to go up,
they're going to get raises, and they're going to be back in here next year
saying, you guys added another 6,000 people, we need
a couple more officers. So it's not something that's going away.
It's just something that we are being asked to— what do we do to adjust
this policy so that we can get to a better place today and
work for a better future tomorrow?
We've had a lot of hard conversations one-on-one. We've had a
lot of dialogue, as we said in that retreat. We've had a lot of
dialogue as we've had those opportunities in public meetings
to have the discussion during the budget sessions.
And I'm just going to say this. I'm proud to serve with the council
members who are to my left and to my right. They are not cowards.
It's not easy to face you, and it's not easy to tell you the truth,
but that's what we've chosen to do.
Yeah, I want to at least answer Melanie's question.
Everything that's been said up here is exactly how I think all of us feel.
And we hope that it's kind of a glimpse into some
of the thought process that we've put into this, the things
that we've wrestled with, the questions that we've been asking ourselves.
But Melanie asked, like, what are the capital projects,
top 3? And for me,
obviously roads, safety, getting kids
to school safely. Those are things where there's no special
fees coming from someplace else. There's no additional dollars coming
from anywhere. And we have a
family of 7 in our house. Wow. and I was
a teacher for 10 years, so it's important for me for both kids and
adults to be able to get where they need to go safely.
Every minute that you spend in your car is time that you're not
with your family. It's time that you can't be at your
kids' games or spending time with your wife or
husband or your aged parents. So, like, roads are
crazy important to me, and they will always be crazy important to me. But the
next 2 things for me are ones that aren't sexy,
and they're not ones that a lot of people think about. But I
want, when each of you flush your toilet, for the stuff that
you flush to leave your house and not ever come back.
And we need a sewer treatment plant to be expanded
so that it can handle what we as a city have. Thank you. We're at
capacity for load, and we need to do something
about it now. And it takes 3+ years to
get a sewer treatment plant built and expanded, and it costs a crap
ton of money. So that's a huge capital project that's important
to me. Crap ton of money. Pun intended.
Oh my gosh, you guys are so quick. I didn't even
think of that. And then the last
of the top 3, but there's like about 40 that are important to me,
are our water sources. The reality
of it is, is we have a ton of water and a really nice aquifer
that's under the ground, but we have woefully
inadequate infrastructure to get that water that
we have up out of the ground, and we don't
have enough tanks to store it in. And just to—
it was the 4th of July week when we put out the request to
all of our commercial businesses, all of our schools, all of our
HOAs, all of our churches. And we said, please don't water.
We said to our residents, please don't water. And we
as a city had already not been watering our parks. So why is that important?
Why do we need the whole water infrastructure?
If we don't have enough water in our tanks replenished at
night, then we can't put fires out. And we
live in like a super wildfire-prone
area. And I don't
want any of the people in our community to lose their house because we couldn't
put their fire out because we didn't have enough infrastructure to get the water out
of the ground. Thank you. And we're working like
crazy. Our staff is working like crazy. A couple months ago,
there was a water line that just like burst in the middle of behind
Scenic Mountain up there, and there were dudes
from our team working late into the night, frankly early into
the morning, and it was muddy and gross. And my husband and
I went and brought them drinks and a couple candy bars. Because I felt bad
that they were working so late. And it was treacherous
for me to walk to bring them stuff. I can't imagine what it was like
for them to work in those conditions. And that's what the people of our
city staff do over and over again. And I just— you
guys elect us because we're the ones that go
and study things out, and then we bring you back information and we make decisions
on your behalf. This is some of the information that we have
and the priorities that we have based off of the things that
you guys have told us. So thank you for being here.
Can we move to like a policy discussion now?
Yeah. Okay. Something that's been on my mind is
how do we prevent this kind of volatility from
happening in the future. We've benefited. I've benefited personally for the last— I've
lived here 20 years and my property tax rate has decreased
as my home value has gone up. I've paid the same nominal dollar
amount. If you don't believe me, go look at your property tax rate—
not the rate, excuse me, the dollar amount for the city
has been the same. Just look at the city.
I didn't believe it when I served on city council. I'm like, there is no
way. I was told that. I went home, pulled out all my tax records,
went back to 2016, pulled out my property tax
rate. It's like $200. What I paid last year is like $210.
The way that property taxes work, it's a flat nominal dollar amount,
but that rate, as your property value is going up, you're paying the same dollar
amount. So our rate has actually been going down, and you can shake
your head no. ASD has been raising,
UFA has been raising, but the city has not been raising.
So everyone listening, go home, pull out your property
taxes, look at the city dollar amount that you've paid. It's about
the same. It's not changed. But the cost
of the sheriff per Protecting your house, that cost has
increased. So where we have failed residents,
and this isn't your fault, it's prior decisions that were made
that maybe they felt like yeah, it's okay. Data centers will come one day,
and then all of our problems will be solved. The mayor
just talked about. I've heard him say that before.
Whenever that day comes, it's not today. We're not there. So.
A couple things that I've thought about, and I would be
curious— this isn't specifically to the rate, but I would
propose that we have a code, and maybe that's something that we can work on,
that requires future city councils each,
whatever that proportion is, whether it's 100% or 50%
or 60% or 10%, whatever we're
looking to kind of set that rate at to cover the
sheriff's contract, I would propose that we have a code that requires
future city councils to come back every single year,
review what that— where the council is at.
If QTS comes online and some of these data
centers are— our property taxes exceed the sheriff's
contract, I would like to see our rate go down, and I would like
to pull that pressure away from the rest But that will only happen
if we have a code in place, a policy strategically
long-term that requires councils to come back and review that
on an annual basis. And I would just be curious if the other
council— we don't need to vote on that tonight, but I'd be curious
if you would support moving forward in that direction. Marcus,
if that is something from a legal standpoint that we can Put
into our city code? Yeah, I mean, you can put it
in the code that as part of the budget process, you're gonna review this,
and the future city councils will either keep that code and follow
it, or they may change the code at a future date, but then they would
go through the public process to do that. I know for me, I would've
been grateful if that existed, because we would've had gradual increases
year to year. So, so that's
one comment I have on the policy. I'd also, uh, be— and
this is more of a legal question for Marcus— the ability for us to
segregate these funds. Um, we're, we're proposing collecting
property taxes, that goes into a general fund. Can those be segregated
by the city into a fund account that just pays specifically for,
uh, Sheriff's Office? Oh, I think he really wants to I don't
want to speak, but I can speak to that matter.
The property taxes will have to be received into the general
fund. At that point, you could— you can still create a
separate fund for public safety, but you would do an operating transfer to send
the revenue over. Would we need a code to require that? It would be a
resolution that we would bring. So this for 2027,
there were— We created a new special revenue fund for public
art and several of those. So we could do that
specifically for the sheriff's contract? Yeah. Okay, thank you.
Yeah, I'm glad you brought that up. That's actually one of the— I talked about
being willing to reduce the property tax as the sales tax
and the MET money starts to come in commensurate
so that that burden doesn't stay. I'm definitely in favor of finding
a solution to that. I also feel pretty strongly
about making sure that we, if we're saying that we're going to put it to
public safety, that there should be something that demonstrates to the citizens
that that's exactly where that's going. So I'm glad that you said that,
Kimberly. That was one of my questions as well. I think that that needs to
be clear. I think that we
need to do our budgets differently. differently, and maybe that's something we need to have
a discussion about at a later date. One of
the things that I feel like that we could have done with this, where we're
proposing a tax increase, I believe we should have had
our current tax rate budget and a separate budget
that is based on what the increase would be so that we could actually have
the very conversation that you guys are asking about. Where would we spend the additional
funds that are being moved from the sales tax. I'll give you my
list of things that I think are important. I'm glad the person asked the 3
top capital projects. In our meeting Tuesday, we talked about
our master transportation plan. That would be pretty sobering for you if you guys were
able to see what that cost actually is. What's even more sobering is when
we sat in a regional meeting to listen to UDOT and the
Mountainland Association of Governments tell us that we're not going to get some of these
roads for 10 or 20 years. Council Member Wood,
$419 million by 2035.
That's Eagle Mountain's portion. That's ours.
The only way that that can be paid for is by bonding or leveraging
debt. We don't have that kind of money.
We have that kind of need. We're still growing.
That's not going to change. We still have that many cars that are being added
every single year. We're being ignored largely
by the state, frankly, about what our needs are.
We're absolutely being ignored by the other side of the county as
they prioritize rapid bus that
are empty, that we all paid for, by the way, with our UTA funds.
When they're building gondolas in Salt Lake County, that should have been funds that should
have come out here and had 2100 North done 4 years ago.
I want you to know that the fight is happening with who you have right
here, and whether you decide to vote us in honestly is really immaterial to me.
If I, if I can't gain your trust by telling you the truth when the
truth sucks, then you need to go on to somebody else. But I'm going to
tell you the one thing you can trust is that I will always tell you
what the truth is, whether you like it or not. And I think I've been
pretty consistent since I started on the Planning Commission with that.
I think every developer will tell you that. I'm, I'm about
what is best for Eagle Mountain as a whole, and I've fought for that.
When we take a look at policies, policies should be things that outlast us.
If we don't do things that are going to benefit the people in the future,
and I do something that is just going to take care of right now,
then I failed. If we don't put a financial plan
in place that you guys can rely on, that's a 5 and a 10 and
a 20-year plan that every council should have to come back and review based
on what the current needs are at the time, then we failed.
And I don't like to fail, frankly. I feel like that,
you know, I had some pretty specific things I wanted to accomplish being on the
council. I've hit a lot of them. There's a couple of them I'm pretty pissed
I still haven't hit them. One of them is for sure making sure that
we're financially sound. And our economic growth has not happened
at the rate that I would like it to. And I'm tired of being told
by people that that's the rate of government. I just don't believe that crap.
I think that there's ways that we can do better. So when
we vote on this today, my vote's going to be based on that. What is
best for you in the future? I'm sorry that it's going to
have the same crappy effect on you that it's having on me and my family.
My wife is not in favor of it, just so you know.
And it's going to have an impact on me and my kids,
whether or not they're able to play certain sports,
etc. But I'm going to tell you,
the decision that we're going to make is going to give us the ability to
start moving traffic. It's going to give us the ability to take care of our
assets. If we let every one of our parks die, guys, it's going to be
three times the amount to fix them. So that's kind of where I stand
with that. The the last thing I want to talk about. Capital projects. Uh,
I'm not firm that all of it should go to capital projects. I really do
think that we are undermanned. Our,
our, uh, labor force is woefully too small.
Uh, and I'm not talking about people that are sitting at desks. I'm talking about
the crews that fix our streets, our water,
our parks. I mean, if you guys knew how
many employees we had at the parks, it'd probably make you mad. I think it's
like 10, isn't it, full-time employees for 68
parks? I mean, that's not going to come
from nowhere. And so when I look at this, I'm like, if I'm going to
vote for this, it damn sure is not going to be for people getting
raises at the top end. We're going to start adding bodies so that we can
tell people we did our very best to improve the quality
of life and quality of services that you should expect no matter where you live.
I support both of those policies you're talking about, by the way.
I wanted to add just a few other things. So the
city council has been fighting very hard to find additional money outside the city
for the city. I spent a week of
my year this year in March with the mayor
back in Washington, D.C., and we worked very diligently
to try to secure federal dollars to come back to support projects
that we have here in Eagle Mountain. To my understanding, it's the first time our
city has ever sent a delegation to Washington, D.C. It's not going to be the
last because we're going to keep beating that drum. That's a week away
from my family. It's a week away from my own job,
but it is worth it to me to try to figure out other methods
to pay for the needs that are here.
I know that Mayor Gray, he was the one that identified some
potential significant savings by restructuring our relationship with Unified Fire.
That's something we're going to experience next year. That was completely on him to
identify that. That could be millions in savings for the city. And I'm
grateful for his leadership in that regard.
We've— other things we're trying to do. We have a volunteer
police force that also helps alleviate pressure
on our sheriff's department. They have no funding.
And Cedar Fort has a fire department that's volunteer, and they don't have enough
funding. So Alex Carter, who's a council
member there in Cedar Fort, and I have put our heads together. We're putting
on a half marathon here in Cedar Valley, October 10th.
With money that will be raised to help our volunteer police and
the volunteer fire. We're trying to come up with ways
to get money from other sources, even small ways.
We're going to be working with the Best Friends Animal Society where
they can provide some free services to help with some animal control stuff. We're adding
those things in there. We're trying to be active, proactive, and we're trying to approach
this from the front, not the back. Yet we are actively engaged
with our state, like Legislature, there was a real potential for the
state to pass a cap on property tax increase.
Had that passed, we would have been in a very difficult scenario,
very, very difficult scenario. And and
I'm glad it didn't. Can we phase this next tax increase?
Part of the issue is what's the state legislature going to do,
and we have to consider that and play from the front instead of the back.
Also, the state legislature has been mentioned that they want to socialize our MET
funds, our municipal energy tax from data centers. That's not fair.
So you need a you need a city council that's going to be lobbying very
very much for you at the state and with the feds to make
sure we get the best results for you. It was also stated that
perhaps the tax increase was to give the city council staff pay increases.
The city council has no staff. Other cities have
city councils with staff. We don't have a staff. It's us.
That's it.
It's been said that we're raising taxes to build a city hall,
and that's false. This has nothing to do with the city hall.
Does the city need a city hall? Yes. A lot of— there was comment saying
you don't need a city hall, you have sufficient here. That's that's an uninformed
decision or uninformed comment, and I would welcome a private discussion with
any of you that feel that that that this building is sufficient.
So I just wanted to clear up some of those things. I think oh
rec center. This has absolutely nothing to do with the rec center, and hopefully sheds
light on why we can't do a rec center yet.
We have so much going on. Let me see. I'm just trying to see.
The other thing I was going to mention is I'm going to tell you the
tale of 2 HOAs because it's been brought up. Well, Craig, you're in real estate,
so you should know that this is not healthy. Let me— it
is my real estate background that it will cause me to vote yes
on some form of tax increase right now, and I will tell you why.
When I was young in my real estate career, actually I wasn't even in real
estate yet at this moment, I was on a board of an HOA Because
I was filling in for a period of time with for someone who could not
be on that board, and that individual said he instructed
me. He said, "Craig, make sure the HOA dues go up." Like,
why do you want the HOA dues to go up? This is a business guy.
Like, why do you want the HOA dues to go up? That's that's the thing
that will hurt you. You're not going to get money back from that. He said,
"Craig, I'm planning. I'm not planning on what's going to happen
to the HOA." this next year. I'm planning at
a minimum for 5 years, but Craig, I'm actually planning for 10 to 20.
And so they increased the HOA dues without a need to
increase the HOA dues. But what did that happen— what,
what effect did that happen? That HOA has never
had a special assessment, ever. When roofs came due, they had
the money for it. When they had to redo parking lots, They had the money
for it. And when properties go on the market in that HOA,
they sell in like a day because of how well
that HOA is maintained. It's because they put— they
budgeted money early on. What's interesting is there
is a subdivision immediately next door to them that did not do that.
It is currently a shuttered facility that will be knocked
down. That is what will happen. We are at a crossroads.
I know people have said, well, you are not listening to the people,
Craig, if you vote for a tax increase because the people don't want it.
Let me give a brief— this is just a 60-second historical
moment. The Battle of Gettysburg, there was
a group that was assigned to protect the flank
on Little Round Top.
When the Confederate Army was coming up the hill, that group came in such
numbers and that they ran out of ammunition.
The troops said, let us— we got to back out.
We don't have any more ammunition.
And their leader said, if we back out now,
our flank caves in and they will come in behind us and we
lose the war. And so he told his troops
that were with him, that were worn and tired,
put on your bayonets. And they did,
and they charged down the hill.
That changed the outcome of the Battle of Gettysburg.
Sometimes leadership requires leading people to a place they do
not want to go because we see a vision that we know
we must obtain. That's what we bring forward to you today that I
ask that you humbly please at least acknowledge to a degree. Thank you.
One question that came up when we were in our retreat and different
discussions through this is, can we create a tax change and
just create it for like a year or 2 and then roll it
back? And the fact is state law doesn't allow you to
do that, but it was something that we as a council were like, yeah,
we could get behind in that, and it's kind of unfortunate that state law doesn't
allow you to do that because there will be additional income coming
into our community soon. But right now we
have to find money to make sure we get everything accomplished.
So I wanted to let you guys know if anybody was wondering, why can't you
just do it for 2 years or a year? It's just not allowed in the
So I just want to point out maybe one,
one additional benchmarking tool if it's helpful.
We, we currently as a city, we are the 9th
fastest growing city in America, not in Utah,
but in the United States. Saratoga Springs, I don't know how they beat us.
It doesn't feel like they did. 20% faster.
Not that it's a competition. I don't want to be the fastest,
but we are. Our rate today,
we are the 2nd lowest in all
of Utah County behind Cedar Fort. So our current rate is
0.000534.
Our— I'll say sister city, Saratoga Springs,
Maybe they've done a better job of managing that rate, but they're at 0.00976.
They are also proposing a 100% increase
to their rate. And I thought about that and I thought Saratoga
Springs has a much, much larger producing commercial
base than we do. They have Costco, Home Depot.
I mean, a lot of our residents shop there. We're actually helping
them with their revenue. Every time you
shop at Costco, you're helping Saratoga Springs. When we shop here,
that helps us from a sales tax point. If this
proposed rate— and I will just say I am not
in support of this rate as proposed.
I think it needs to be lower. It needs to be certainly somewhere in
the middle. If we increase,
if we change our rate from 0.0005,
and there's some other numbers after that, but that'll suffice for
my point I'm gonna make. If we just doubled our rate to 0.0011%,
that would, new revenue generated
would be $3.4 million. So— To be fair to
our conversation, all of those dollars would go to the sheriff's office.
That would free up about roughly just under $2 million of
sales tax revenue that's currently supporting that contract.
I think at a bare minimum, given all the road infrastructure
we have, the staffing, getting our employees just to
90% of the median, That would be the
lowest that I would consider. But after this
increase, Saratoga Springs— and again, I'm just kind of benchmarking
because they are close to us, but I do think they have a better commercial
base than we do, although we're working on it as
hard as we can. We have an economic director that is traveling all over
the country, beating on every— knocking on every door, beating every bush.
I get emails from her Every it feels like every other day of who
she's meeting with, who she's talking to, to try to build
out our commercial base. But with with the proposed increase,
Saratoga Springs would land at about point zero zero one five,
and the next city down from there at point zero zero one four
is Ben's old employer Santaquin City.
So I would just encourage the
council to consider. backing off that number
of 0.0017. And I, I would love to,
to hear an argument. You know, we can go high. We've, we've heard several
residents that have come here tonight, and I'm mindful
that we have 2 District 1 elementaries in our
city. Those families, it's tight. Title 1.
Oh, I'm sorry, what did I say? Title 1. What did I say? District 1.
District 1? Yeah. That would be college football, I think.
Title 1, excuse me. It's getting late.
But we have 2 Title 1 elementaries, and that just means that the families— we
do have families that are— that will be sensitive to this tax increase.
And so in my mind, I'm trying to balance that
along with we have needs within the city we have not kept
up. And again, that's not the residents' fault. That is a, I think, a failure
of policy within our city for the last decade. But that, that's kind of where
I'm, where I'm landing, is to come somewhere closer
to maybe where Saratoga Springs is, um,
that has a similar population rate, although they do have a better commercial
base. Hey, just a point of
clarification, if that's okay. Uh, I don't think Saratoga's rate's
100%. I think it's closer to 50.
53%. So they're at today— their
rate today, excuse me, is 0.00976,
and after their increase, they'll be at 0.0015.
So they'll go up 6 points.
Let's talk. They don't want to sit here and listen to us blabber anymore.
Well, sorry, what do we want to do? Look, I, I'm going
to tell you that I've, I've kind of looked at this and I've, uh,
I, I've talked to a couple of council members individually and
there's such a tremendous need, but I feel like that, that probably
a better balance is to bring the rate down a little bit. And I could
get behind where Council Member Hewish is at. He and I have actually talked about
this. For me, I think the 1, the 1, 5, however many
zeros in the 1,500, I don't
know what that percentage is, but for me, that's perhaps a
more appropriate number. Also recognizing that,
and I hate to even tell the citizens this, but next year we're gonna be
right back here again as we go through the UFSA.
And frankly, it'll give us a year to evaluate where things go and to
take a look at, at any perhaps increases in revenues
that we see and allow us to make an adjustment then. So that's,
that's what I'm thinking.
Can I— oh, I was just going to say, I will say Council Member Hewish
brought up, we're just going to call it the 1-1. That's the median of what's
going on in our county, and that really is the bare minimum of what
we could do. It still gives us a revenue
shortfall of $3.3 million. So,
um, I,
I think we should look at that. But I also am sensitive to the
fact that because we haven't changed anything for so, so long,
we are so far off the mark of other cities our size like
Saratoga And they're at the 1.5.
And right now, the one you guys
got as a tax statement all said 1.7.
So it is a significant step down from that.
And it's probably in the 65th to 70th percentile
of what's going on in the county as far So
one of the gentlemen that spoke earlier read a
private email that I had exchanged with him. I didn't realize it would be read,
and I'm fine that he read it, but that email openly stated that
I was already considering the 1.7% a
reduction from 1.7. So I'm definitely, definitely open to considering
a number that's different than the 1.7 number.
What number do you suggest? I've,
I've been around 1.5 is when— is about— is what I've been looking
at. I want
to manage expectations because honestly, where we land on the numbers,
we're going to be looking at this again. And I think that you need to
be aware of that. We need to be able to evaluate every year, uh,
where we actually land. Going the
other direction with this, that means that we're going to have to say no to
things. And I think if you're okay with that as citizens
and you're like, we understand there's not money for us to do all the trails,
there's not money for us to keep our parks where they need
to be, we don't have enough people to even take care of those and you'll
rally around us and help us come up with some options
to be able to deal with some of these things, then it's probably something
that we can get behind because then we're dealing with this as a community.
But if we continue on the path that was laid for us,
everything is going to be in disrepair
that's going to cost 2 and 3 times the amount to bring it back to
a level that's acceptable. So I So,
though I am not excited about going to the 0.15,
because I feel like that is, if we felt like
that's what it was, we should have started with that, frankly. I heard
what you said too, and I felt what each one of you said about how
it's impacting your homes.
So maybe that's the direction we need to go for this year. We all hope
and pray that when QTS starts this next month,
that those funds bring the revenue that we've all been
waiting for, that we've all been promised, and that as these other buildings
are built for Facebook and QTS, that we realize those funds.
I hope this isn't the last time you're here.
We're better when you come in here pissed off and ready to
fight. Frankly, uh, it makes us better at
making the decisions that we're— that we have to make, but we also need you
to stand side by side with us when we make the decision and help us
to meet the shortfalls. So that's where I'm at.
Hey, just for the benefit of the residents, I know we've talked about this
a lot, uh, in other meetings, but, uh,
using numbers like 15, 17 is— it can get confusing.
Uh, maybe you could refer it to a dollar amount if
it's possible, or just help us understand where that's going.
So just, just to clarify, Mayor, what, what we're
discussing is reducing the, the proposed
tax increase rate to 0.0015.
That would be from 0.0017.
Yeah, and I don't think anybody there besides us understands what dollar
amount that So that's what I'm trying to
tell you. Go ahead.
So here, it's somewhere in the middle in terms of like a
tax rate. So an annual— sorry, an average home annual increase
over the certified rate, it would land somewhere between $245 to
$268 because we're sort of proposing something in between 2
numbers I'm looking at. Call it like $2.55 or something,
divide that by 12, or sorry, divide that by 365.
So it's like a 69-cent-per-day increase, something like
that. Kimberly, can you give us a number? Can you do the math?
I've got the exact math.
Yeah, it ends up being, I can get you an exact number.
No, no, not the tax rate, 'cause the breakdowns we have go by
5% each. And so, so the actual number,
it would be a 183.02% increase is
what I— is what I'm— so what I'm seeing is this: the annual revenue— sorry,
the net revenue above the certified rate would be $5,591,594,
which represents a 183.02% increase instead of a 220%.
But I was just saying the net effect to the residents is closer to like
70 cents per day. Yes. On the average. That's what I was talking about,
is the, the net revenue, Craig. So thank you. That's— I think that helps
everybody understand what it means. We're talking about, uh, $5.5 million,
uh, $250 a year,
things like that, around that 0.1 or 0.0015.
Is there any other comments on rate
or, or dollar amounts? I've heard a few opinions.
I kind of lost track. I think I heard Councilmember Whiting say around the,
the $5.5 million.
It's not appropriate. Public hearing time has passed.
If, if there's no further discussion, I will entertain a motion. I haven't
seen anybody raise their hand, so— Mayor,
I'll make a motion. Okay.
And then, uh, hopefully we're listening to this, so make sure I do this right,
but I move that the City Council hereby approves and adopts a
property tax rate of 0.001500
for fiscal year 2026 to 2027. This rate exceeds the certified
tax rate of 0.000530
and will result in an increase in the city's ad valorem property
tax budgeted revenue of approximately $5,591,594.
For— let's see— or
183.02% above
the city's property tax budgeted revenue for the prior year,
exclusive of new growth. Second.
Okay, we do have a motion by Council Member Whiting and second by Council Member
Wright. Either Marcus or Lacey,
do you feel you understand the motion and is it
clear?
I want to clarify the tax, the 0.0015,
correct? Okay, thank you.
Yep. Is there any other questions on the motion?
Just one question for Marcus. If we have a desire to put a policy
in place for this, is this something that we do at this
time as a condition, or do we bring that back at a later date?
I think that's something you'd bring back later. If you're talking about adopting an ordinance
requiring, say, to look at it every year, as was suggested earlier,
or adopting a resolution at a
later date that after it comes into the general fund that be
segregated into a separate fund, then that would come out
at another meeting. Thank you. I think
that we need to definitely address that in our next City Council meeting.
So no other questions?
Okay, not seeing any other questions, uh, we'll go ahead and start
a vote. We'll start with Councilmember Wood. Yes.
Councilmember Whiting. Yes.
Councilmember Wright? Yes. Councilmember Clark?
Yes. And Councilmember Hewish? Yes.
Okay, that passes 5-0 and
carries. Um, that is the
last item on our agenda other than one other
item. Motion to adjourn.
Second. Okay, was that Councilmember Wood and Councilmember Wright?
And all in favor of the motion, please say
aye. Aye. Any opposed?
Seeing none, we will adjourn the meeting at 10:38.
Thank you.